[Music]
foreign
hi everybody thanks for watching our
little pre-show there with hope you
enjoyed Mary's talk and some messages
from our sponsors
excited to have you all here we're gonna
start the theme Reveal video very soon
excited to be here Tim
I know you've been bugging me all week
to find out the theme
and it's finally here all the pestering
um I'm sorry if I was getting annoying I
just want to know the theme right
I know everybody out there does so we're
excited to reveal it uh
you're on me Charlie if you're talking
yeah it's uh it's a good theme so I hope
you're all excited for it
you find out in a couple of minutes
oh a couple of minutes yeah any hints at
all that you're willing to give
oh
no no
I like reeled me and I'm like oh my God
they're gonna give me a hint and then
nope nothing
no advices from us darn it
darn it
super tight-lipped at least I know if I
ever have a secret y'all are the ones
that are going to keep it
absolutely we're very good at keeping
secrets
it's hard to do all year but it's this
is what we look forward to so
excited for everybody to find out
Super Bowl for games
pretty much
yes
I'm excited
if for anybody out there watching that
doesn't know I'm Tim I'm the executive
director you'll hear from me in a bit on
the uh
on this on the keynote reveal theme
reveal the video
I'm Charlie I'm director of operations
for Global game jam and hopefully you
won't hear from me at all for the rest
of this
Charles will be backstage helping out
uh and I'm mac and cheese please you can
call me back and I'm going to be one of
the hosts uh for our Global game Jam
uh I'm Zena Lawson I'm director of
technology so if something goes wrong
with the website I'll be the one to
contact
um
somewhere on the internet answering
everyone's DMS and
whatever you have in mind
and we have two more amazing hosts uh
along with Mac we have Alana Pierce and
Mary Kenny are going to be helping
um
Mary uh Alana will be here from 10 30.
and Mac will be supporting us until then
so
it's all very exciting
yeah it is very exciting
reviews
it's like every minute we're chugging
closer and closer
yeah why don't we uh I know everybody's
excited to wait for it waiting for it uh
patiently can't wait to find out
why don't we get right to it I suppose
see on the other side
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Tim cullings the executive director
of global game gym and welcome to Global
game Jam 2023 and for the first time
we're welcoming Global game gym next
2023 at the same time as ggj and we're
excited to have you all here with us and
excited for the theme reveal of course
that's about to happen in a few short
minutes first of all we'd like to say
thank you though to our board our staff
our all of our committee members our
regional organizers our site organizers
our volunteers our great keynote
speakers and of course our sponsors who
make this whole thing possible please
make sure that during the gym or before
to visit our sponsor page and check out
all of the great offers that the
sponsors have a lot of them are free
offers for technology tools engines all
to make your jam a lot a lot easier a
lot more fun I let you try to learn some
new things with new tools and technology
so definitely make sure you go and check
that out and thank you thanks to all our
sponsors again for making this possible
uh and most of all sometime during this
weekend find and thank your site
organizers during the gym or whatever
time period you're doing this gym uh
definitely give them a nice thank you
for all the hard work that they've done
over the last weeks months who knows how
long they've been putting into this but
they deserve a lot of credit for all the
work that they do to host a great event
for you all that's about to get started
uh so yeah definitely thank your site
organizers and thanks from myself to you
personally out there I've I'm I still am
a site organizer here in Seattle
Washington so I know what you've been
going through uh and we really
appreciate all the hard work that you do
to help us make this event what it is
and what and do something great for your
community
uh as to for all your definitely uh
thanks to all of our Jammers out there
uh who are about to participate whether
this is your first Global game gym your
second Global game Jam your fifth your
10th your 15th whatever you're about to
have a great time you're in the right
place uh this is where you come to learn
to meet new people to make new friends
to make some games and make some
memories
and everybody is in a similar situation
uh they've either done this before or
they haven't
and you know look to your look to the
people around the room look to the
people on your online platform uh to
help you along the way to maybe make a
new friend that you've never met before
to hear some of their ideas about making
games
and uh what kind of games that they want
to make during the gym uh just listen to
each other support each other make sure
you get some rest
eat some good food and uh have a great
time and yeah we're excited so have uh
enjoy Global game jam and Global game
Jam next 2023 thanks everybody
foreign
[Music]
I'm the regional coordinator of global
game Jam in Ukraine and also I'm an
indie game developer and associate
professor of Robert alvordi economical
and technological Institute
today I'd like to talk about the
community
one of the core missions of the global
game Jam is to bring together people who
are fond of game development
imagine a single person who's making
games at home and showing them only to
the close friends and family
they might not have the faintest idea on
how many people share the same passion
to game development in their own city in
the country or in the whole world until
they meet likely minded people at the
jam location
[Music]
Ukraine joined the worldwide community
of global game Jam in 2016. and this
brought such an exciting feeling of
connection and unification
it is so inspiring to look at the map
and see that while you are brainstorming
the game theme producing visuals or
fixing those naughty bugs which always
appear 10 minutes before the game
submission thousands of people in
hundreds of cities across the whole
world are doing the same
online streams and cross location video
interviews further enhance this sense of
belonging
you see that you are not alone
and so many people will understand you
it is incredible
Global game Jam in Ukraine also served
as a focal point for the local Game Dev
communities growth
after the initial boost given by global
game Jam in the beginning of the year in
January or February we kept the
community living by other events and
sessions many teams continue to work on
their games afterwards and then they
showcased these games at the
international conferences
often at these conferences they had
chance to meet face to face the global
game Jam participants from other
countries and it is so joyful helpful
and inspiring
even switching to the online mode due to
the pandemics didn't slow down the
community creativity last Global game
Jam we had over 350 developers and 55
games
made in Ukraine
we were looking forward to expand all
those exciting games to establish new
connections and launch new activities
but then on the 24th of February 2022
was the day when Russia started the
full-scale invasion against Ukraine and
when the first Russian missiles stroke
Ukrainian cities killing innocent people
as soon as the news reached the other
countries we started receiving messages
from our friends worldwide
this is another powerful sign of
connection in the worldwide game
development Community which we
experienced
the simple question how are you gained a
whole new meaning for the ukrainians
since then
from a simple greeting phrase it changed
to a sign indicating that the person
asking does really care
and this helped us stand
your care your support to those
ukrainians who had to leave the country
to those who had to stay and fight
to those who love their houses Health
loved ones
all this helps
we are deeply thankful to all the help
and support we are receiving from you
our friends
today if you look at the global game Jam
map you won't see locations in Ukraine
but this is a safety measure
no place in Ukraine can be saved from
being a name of the Russian missiles
so we have to run our locations in the
stealth mode
we hope to show you the games from
Ukraine after the gem
and we never forget that if we have a
chance to make games now
this is all thanks to the protection of
Ukrainian Defense Forces and help we are
receiving from our friends from the
whole world
sometimes it is said that games are a
way to escape from reality
sadly but the reality might be such that
it doesn't allow you to escape
War which is right now fought against
Ukraine is such a case
and we must face this reality together
therefore I ask you to keep supporting
Ukraine by increasing awareness and the
Nations
the respond Game Dev and the bombs it is
run by the game development conference
organizers
there is a comeback alive fund
there is a president's initiative United
24.
it is possible to select a direction you
want to help Medical Aid defense or a
building
your health can literally save lives
thank you
for gtj 2023 I wish you first of all
peaceful gem
sometimes we don't notice something
until it's lost
use this gem as a chance to strengthen
your community connections
look at the people at your location if
you are German physically or at your
chat if online
don't be too shy to come to people
around you and tell about yourself
remember that those people have the same
interests as you do
and if you feel that you have
possibility help less experienced game
gem participants
ask how are you question in a meaningful
way
have great and peaceful Gem and good
luck to you
[Music]
foreign
founder and executive director of code
to inspire the first coding school for
girls and women in Afghanistan it's my
pleasure to welcome you all to the 23
Global game Jam
add code to inspire we address The
Perennial economic cultural and
patriarchal challenges that girls and
women in Afghanistan face by providing
one year after school program in a safe
environment to date we've educated more
than 350 girls in our coding and graphic
design classes by providing a free
technical education in a safe
environment we want to narrow the gender
gap in education participation social
empowerment and economic growth in
Afghanistan in 2019 a group of our
students in the game development class
came up with the idea to create a game
with the female superhero from
Afghanistan the Afghan Hero game girl
the game features a young Afghan girl
whose parents are captured by a witch
our students wanted to create a game
that included a girl who looked like
them in a heroic decision-making role so
that the other young women could see
themselves as powerful figures knowledge
is power and technology is the tool for
this empowerment gaming is a great way
for both educational and entertainment
purposes that's why we use this tool as
a way to raise more awareness in the
community about women in technology and
gaming sadly with what happened in
Afghanistan August 2021 with the Taliban
taking over the country girls and women
of Afghanistan since then have been
deprived to access basic fundamental
human rights such as education work
freedom of movement that many girls
around the world are taking it for
granted during this critical moment for
the girls and women of Afghanistan code
to inspire remains resilient in the
fight to keep educating more girls and
provide more opportunities for them to
access global economy in order to
support themselves and change their
lives and their family's future
we want to make sure that we can provide
any opportunity to these girls that any
young girl deserve around the world as
Rumi 13th century Farsi poet said where
the Israel when there is hope for a
treasure girls and women of Afghanistan
are treasures and by investing in their
education we are going to build
Afghanistan 2.0 I wish you all the best
with much inspiration and creativity to
change the world for a better place
thank you so much
[Music]
so we saw we were making an action game
right yeah in a fantasy world we've
been in the online multiplayer what what
dude are you crazy making multiplayer
games is a hundred times harder than
single player
yeah you're right multiplayer is usually
a hundred times harder but with
coherence it's only 17 times harder only
17 that's insane you mean coherence at
coherence IO right right
coherence really is the fastest way to
make multiplayer games even during a
game Jam wouldn't it be cool if you
could play your game together online hey
guys look I already got something
running wow seriously yeah just two
bucks is sinking but it's a start ah
Synergy see if you want to try it
yourself you can get more information at
coherence.io ggjj
[Music]
thank you
hi my name is Jabari Ali and I am a
systems designer with skydance
interactive and an innovation educator
with the hidden genius project and I'm
very excited to welcome you to the
global game Jam
um wow this is going to be quite a jam I
hope you're ready I hope you're excited
even though man let's do it right and so
for me game jams has been just an
inspiration right it really gave me that
courage to uh really make this my career
making gains
um I actually started out in audio doing
music and sound design
um and then slowly after going to jams
and finding cool people to make games
with I started to learn how to do other
things and started learning how to do
gameplay design gameplay engineering UI
project management the whole thing
and so I really recommend
um you know maybe you're on the fence or
you're not sure if you have the time I
really recommend
doing the jam it's gonna be great for
you and and the biggest thing is just
understanding that the the commitment
level like how intense it is is up to
you right you can keep it light you can
keep it small or you can go all in and
you know do crazy all-nighters and make
something you know make something huge
um but it's just about the experience
right
and so my first little piece of advice
actually is understanding the why why do
you want to do the jam so for me
um
it started out with I just wanted to
have fun I was like wow I can make a
game and I can you know kick it with
some fellow nerds and just be weird and
just be crazy and make some cool stuff
um and so that was my why to begin with
right so I kept it real light-hearted
and just wanted to have fun and share my
skills and kind of get better
um but you know maybe you have a
different thing maybe you want to go in
there you want to make some real strong
contacts and you want to find some
people to work with later on on major
projects or maybe you've got uh some
things you've been working on that
you're really good at but you need a
team to actually get it out there you
know you're you're an artist but you
need a coder to work with to get your
art in the game you know whatever your
why is understand it
um and really make that part of your
focus right that will keep you motivated
throughout the jam keep you centered
keep you focused okay so figure out your
why and then the next really important
thing to do is uh
what are you bringing to the table what
are your strengths right and and don't
um don't go back right it's okay to
um you know Flex a little bit right
because a lot of people that you're
probably working with they haven't met
you before they haven't seen what you're
doing right so uh get your portfolio
together don't be shy let people know
what you can do
um and really think about okay hey this
is what I can bring to the table and I
actually really recommend that even if
you're uh
jack of all trades or hey I can do
anything I really recommend that you
pick one thing to focus on for the gym
right even if you can do art code design
and all that pick one maybe you're like
hey this time I'm just gonna do design
and that can really allow you to hone
that skill but also give other people
the opportunity to you know pick up
those other areas right and it's really
uh beneficial to work on a team you make
great connections you're able to get
more done so I recommend that you figure
out
what your strength is what your role
what role do you want to have for the
gym
and then find other people to work with
right and
if you have your own idea please write a
a game design document now it doesn't
have to be long it could be just half a
page
but um just having a little something to
keep everybody centered right will go a
long way right so uh yeah figure out
what do you want to do what is your role
for this jam and then
you know fill in the blanks right hop on
the forums hop in the Discord hop on the
social media right talk to people share
your portfolio comment on other people's
posts and just really get yourself out
there right and don't be shy
so what's your role what do you need
find your team okay
um and it's okay if you don't know right
away maybe you all just like Platformers
and you're like Hey we're gonna make
something but we're figuring it out
right
so
find your team find the game that you're
gonna make
and then when you do keep it simple you
don't have a lot of time okay it'll go
behind the blink of an eye right so
um one mechanic right maybe your
mechanic is just jumping or dashing
through walls or uh you know being able
to I don't know throw cheesecake
whatever it is right
um pick your one mechanic
um and then make sure it's fun okay uh
don't wait till day three to
see uh If the mechanic is even fun you
want to experience that mechanic on the
first day honestly within the first few
hours that's true that is priority
number one
what is the mechanic
design it and be able to actually
experience it in the game in an actual
build tubes don't stay in the editor
don't too much time in the editor if you
want to play a test early and often okay
in an actual build okay
um and then yeah you'll hear this a lot
honestly you want to be kind of on top
of your scheduling and your roadmap
right day one get your mechanic day two
get the complete slice of the game I can
play from beginning to end right I have
a start screen I have a victory screen
right and then day three now I'm making
it nice and pretty with all the bells
and whistles and the animations and the
sound effects and the music and all of
that okay
um and remember
it just is a demo a demo is enough it
doesn't have to be the full game you
know it could be one level it could take
five minutes to play uh the game that
you're making you know you can keep it
light right don't put too much of a
burden on yourself okay
um
but yeah just really think about uh that
first little bit the why you know here
just to have fun are you here to make
connections are you here to hone your
skills maybe you know all three maybe
something else but think about your why
let that be your ground let that be your
focus
um and yeah most of all please you know
have fun meet some cool people and uh
and don't be afraid to let it carry on
after the jam honestly
um my first Jam we went on to work on
some really cool projects afterwards
um you know so yeah if you meet some
people you really like working with then
you know keep making games with them or
if you make a project that's just wow
this is so amazing yeah continue that
project afterwards right
um
but yeah super excited for this Jam I
hope you are too
um yeah and best of luck to you have fun
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
well hello
Alana Roots hello that's the theme I
know Roots is uh Roots is very cool
because I feel like there are so many
things that you can get out of that like
obviously my head immediately goes to a
tree which makes me very lazy
too there's so many different ways you
can take this yeah I feel like what else
do we go for roots there's a root of a
cause you can have uh rude in terms of
mathematics yeah just looking up the web
root apparently there's an insurance
company called root Insurance all right
probably not gonna go with that one uh
the basic cause the origin of Sundown
yeah there's a lot of options there
which is which is really cool and I also
feel like it ties really well into a lot
of the
um the just the global themes like what
are the roots as humans where do we come
from where do we come from where do we
go it's a very cool one
ah I'm excited to see what all the
gamers and Jammers come up with for this
this is this is going to be huge to see
how everyone from around the world
interprets Roots 100 and I think the
thing that's always really exciting to
me is like outside of like a theme of A
game if we can see people tie Roots into
uh actual gameplay like maybe there's
some sort of growth thing maybe there's
some sort of tracking thing like all the
options for you know I think it's always
really fun to watch things come out of
global game jams that aren't just taking
the wood and making it tie into the
story somehow they tie it into mechanics
that's I have nothing in my head right
now so I imagine I do brainstorming
the first thing that comes to mind is
like thinking of like a skill tree and
the roots are like growing to where your
skills are or something that could be
really fun yeah I don't know how much
time that takes but maybe maybe not a
weekend but and based on some uh of the
conferences we've had recently I feel
like there are a lot of farming life
Sims very popular right now Again
difficult to make but maybe we get some
like botany Sims like maybe it's super
literal like that could be yeah I'll
play all of them and lose my whole life
to it to be honest so right or even uh
incorporating like mushrooms and like
the root systems that are just all over
the forest floor and and just connection
really yeah definitely a lot of very
cool options
um we'd love to see how everyone in the
in the chat feels about it to the person
who asked is this live the answer is yes
um going back to your roots that's a
good one that is a good one
and we've got could be personal Roots
personal stories for sure hello welcome
everybody welcome
morning hey there uh how's everybody
feeling about the theme
amazing
that's also really amazing it's a really
good one it's an amazing video also not
not only a theme like it's very
inspiring have a lot of things and ideas
yeah it is a very nicely made video some
gorgeous music in there too I want to
shout out who I've made that music it's
really lovely
um what was the the first thing that
came to any of your heads when you heard
roots
uh I I think for foreign I think for me
I uh I will go for Origins so like uh
not not only a tree and have the roots
know the origin of the thing so even in
words like the origin of the word uh and
in Arabic language we call the jetra
Laura which is the origin of the of the
language where it comes from so maybe
the origin of the problem origin of the
challenge something in your life the
origin of it and you try to fix it you
think it might be a really interesting
one absolutely out of that uh how about
you Travis
um I actually sort of thought about tree
roots to begin with but those are a
foundation for something and so what
comes from the tree roots uh is sort of
where my my head started going with
immediate immediately after they're the
things that grow out from that solid
foundation that you build up from uh and
really not fully explored yet but I I
want to think on it for a little bit and
see where that particular one goes
there's one fun little image in that
that uh teaser trailer too of a
mathematical square root yeah yeah
there's something there and I have no
clue what it is yet there is a concept
that exists don't tell me a math games
don't tell me math games
A friend of mine has uh he's a Game Dev
and his daughter is 12 years old and she
published a mathematics game on Steam
and it has extremely positive reviews
and that was one of the first things I
thought of that I was like there's so
many options that you can make with math
games even if it's really simple people
who are very young can get into that
which is really really cool yeah
oh good to know the graphics and
animations are created by the amazing
team which is at
randovando.tv on Instagram and they do
look really really good I've got the
show they really do gorgeous artwork on
here yeah it's very very cool
um Astra if you are currently muted but
how did you feel about the theme
honestly when we were going through all
the themes we had uh this was something
that stood out to all of us because when
we saw we just paused and we were like
we could make like 10 different games
just from this one word because of you
know all the different ideas that stem
from the word roots so you know each of
us started spitballing different ideas
and some of us started with trees some
of us started with tea some of us went
to math some of us like I don't know
because we will speak Arabic we both
went to the root of the word and we you
know we bonded over this as well so I
honestly think the kind of ideas that
people are going to come up in this game
Jam are gonna be phenomenal because uh
there's no need to think outside the box
because the box is so big to the extent
that there are so many things that you
can do with it so I'm just genuinely
excited to see this especially since
game jams to me have always been about
um having fun with unique ideas and just
exploring things that you're gonna throw
away after a while so might as well do
something funky and silly with it and
what better way to do this than with a
bit of inspiration from the theme so
yeah I definitely think it's it's uh
nice to have a theme that's not very
restrictive that there are so many
options here right because it means we
can get totally different things to
different people and they can use their
creativity and cling to whichever part
of the word root that they relate to the
most which is really cool absolutely
yeah I think this team evolves during
our process
first as probably said you think root of
the three roots of the mankind but now
that we have talked about it
which is many things yeah
I think this is Awesome theme an awesome
video thank you for the audio theme for
chats
yeah the whole intro was was absolutely
awesome and it was um really nice to
hear from Ukraine as well I think and uh
to hear that they're going to be
basically like stealth
uh making games which was you know
thoughts to everybody in Ukraine that's
absolutely terrifying but I also love
that the community is backing them on
that I think that that's just so awesome
that everyone's like still get involved
don't miss out on this opportunity we
still want you here
it was very very cool to hear that
perspective in the intro as well I think
it's super important um
definitely
goes with the theme of global game Jam
as well obviously very very cool
um someone in the chat said can we
repeat what the theme is the theme is
roots roots and idea in twitch chat hey
just said nerve Roots as well
oh yeah you can have a of things
relating to nerves there's you have so
many options it's kind of intimidating
um yeah for any of you who have been
involved in game jams before where do
you think you start like what's step one
after you've heard the theme is is it
just a big brainstorm meeting
mm-hmm
a lot of staring at white boards yeah
seeing what sticks it's all be like for
me the first thing I just type type it
on uh on the Google and see what type of
things should I get like pictures and
things like this uh maybe checking the
video again like frame by frame and
checking each ideas what one of the
pictures is like the tooth the root of
the tooth this is like something this is
something really out of the box
exactly so things like this it will
trigger and then we start like a very
simple uh line of how the game will be
like what's what's the main idea what's
the main goal of it maybe this is like
the few hours
I think I've done five game jams at this
point and my start is also exactly the
same thing which is Google so probably a
lot of people
people just uh I used Pinterest once
which I think would actually be really
interesting for me because you just see
Aggregates of kind of picture boards
people put together and you can think of
something that you never would have uh
thought of before which is which is
really cool
um we do also have
the diversifiers as well
which you know make things even more
interesting so I think that diversifiers
we have this year are making memories
um which is create a game that has at
least one moment that everyone who plays
will remember it which I would hope
would happen regardless but that's still
a really cool one to like actually
really try to tie into
um and then there's dungeon master which
is using the unity and a editor as a
mechanical tool in your game one player
can join from the editor at any time to
affect the world in a way that ordinary
players can't which is also awesome
entries using coherence multiplayer
eligible for ten thousand dollar prize
pool
very cool
the world is about a place of all
creators in it which is build a game
where the player commands a large group
of characters while many players played
together to achieve an objective the
yahaha multiplayer challenge which is
use the yaha studio platform to create a
game that is suitable for multiplayer
social scenarios definitely a lot of
multiplayer stuff here which is like
very much again in the theme of
community hidden heritage
please only use this device if you're a
team based in the UK because it's from
the UK games fund and that is select a
local Landmark or place of cultural
historical interest it can be fact
Fiction with a legend too close close to
your team's physical location and use it
as inspiration for your game ideas I'm
looking forward to seeing some of those
learn some more about the UK in the
process
um there I could probably list these for
a long time but it was really cool to
see some accessibility suggestions art
suggestions audio suggestions so I'm
sure we'll cover those uh further as the
as the jam goes on but the diversifiers
are very cool let me drop the Link in
the twitch chat for anyone who hasn't
seen it yeah
you can check them out they are they are
awesome is there anything um anyone is
like particularly excited to see that we
haven't already covered regarding Roots
like
other than just I just want to see
different ideas really but yeah there's
some real nice songs about the roots so
maybe you can try to use it as well on
Spotify
besides Google
yeah that's a good idea
using this is probably very interesting
like taking the lyrics of the song and
maybe
definitely yeah an old TV show too
called roots
maybe not
oh so maybe like some sitcom action
who knows there's so many different
Avenues and and with it being Global
everyone different cultures can
interpret it so differently so I think
we're gonna get a lot of interesting
games this Jam
yeah very very excited
um to see what everyone comes up with
and yeah for anyone who's not aware
um majority of the time you can play
games that are part of game jam and
you'll get a whole bunch of really
different things some of them are really
short so a lot of time it's really easy
to get through a lot of them and it's a
really cool way to learn about different
teams from all over the world as well so
I highly recommend doing that one
they're all actually available to play
they've just gotten the theme so give
everybody a second it doesn't quite work
that quickly but um yeah it's always
really really fun to actually jump
through
um also
so we uh have some more suggestions in
chat that I think are cool a cooking
game root vegetables and ginger that's
good
and make sure I'm not as frustrated as I
am when I play overcooked yeah
anything slightly less frustrating
that's a person that was a Roots TV show
yeah someone wrote carrots are Roots
which is interesting and the things are
coming like a bunny theme game oh yeah
yeah that's good yeah
and then we've got root directory as in
Computing yeah you could do some very
cool stuff with that apparently I
wouldn't even thought of that that's
great yeah yeah historic related things
will be Roots also anything related to
history maybe yeah but
potatoes are root vegetables my ferret's
name is potato therefore my game is
about my ferret hell yeah dude hey go
for it I want the ferret game next to
the bunny game let's do it
that's awesome oh hey Roots see hadn't
even thought of that oh yeah
very cool tons of great ideas coming up
and this has just been like what a few
minutes since we've revealed the theme
and yeah people are just like churning
out tons and tons of things so it's
really exciting to see what's gonna be
made at the end of the day as well
definitely
yeah
you could watch the theme Reveal video
again
after some brainstorming yeah so I can
link that in the twitch chat as well
because we have
just the theme Reveal video by itself
which is it is really lovely um so for
anyone who wants to check that out
go red I'll put that in YouTube as well
this one here
um
it is very very very pretty
yeah really really impressed by the art
there
um definitely a lot of imagery that just
I wouldn't have expected to see which
means that we've kind of got a a good
beginning point I think a lot of very
very cool stuff in there
yeah it looks awesome yeah root
vegetables if you if you lose the game
you have to eat a turnip definitely
going to be a lot of root vegetables I
think it'll just be what people do with
it also I've never eaten a turnip
that could be bad Punishment No
but technically there is no losing in a
game dream
anyone who participates is winning and I
get asked all the time how I got into
game development and my literal
beginning was game jams because I was
like I don't know how to get experience
as a video game right up but that's what
I want to do for a living
how do I even begin with that and to
understand how different departments
work with each other and how that
communication Works um I did a bunch of
game jams which is easy to do even when
you're working full-time if you want to
get into Game Dev I highly highly highly
recommend it it gives you like real
world experience real idea of the
problem solving that is majority of what
your job will be if you work in Game Dev
to be honest
uh so I definitely definitely recommend
taking a part of it and having a look at
uh
how everybody does things this year so
you can get some ideas oh the link
didn't post in twitch chat sorry I'm
probably not a mod
um many uh like many successful games
came out from uh from game jumps uh yeah
probably like like even I know people
who were like working on a big project
then they take a break to make a game in
two days or three days this game became
the hit of of the year yeah of their
original games so yeah it's very very
cool
there are word roots also oh of course
there are you could do something with
Latin
um that would be cool cultural Roots
different cultures could be great for
different countries participating I
think that's the idea that currently
excites me the much the most especially
after what you guys were saying about
Arabic I was like oh there's so many
ways to learn about different cultures
and different languages through this
that maybe some other words don't
potentially give us access to
necessarily so sure that definitely
seems very very cool
yeah word roots is huge in the Arabic
language so that's what somebody just
said I know you guys touched on that but
can you elaborate on it a little bit
more for anyone who's not familiar with
with what that means
so uh so so for example when when you
have like a
like I'm trying to to make it as simple
as uh and saying it in English so for
example when you say I don't know like
um okay you walk and there is like
walking so the origin of walking it's
from the word walk and not exactly like
that but something like this in the
Arabic so there is like the word is
coming all from the origin so maybe like
it's a big word that have like maybe
eight letters but the origin of it it's
like three letters or four letters and
it can be manipulated into many meanings
based on the yeah
based on the evolution of this world
let's see that's very cool yeah it's
like tons of Arabic words can go down to
three letters as the word of origin and
then depending on the kind of accents
you put they could completely change
their meaning so it's just tons of fun
to see something like this happen uh
it's something I want to look into to
see if I'm going to make in this Jam but
we'll see I guess it depends on who I
team up with
that is very very cool and something
that yeah again just like culturally
very different something I didn't know
about that we've all learned about today
so that's awesome
[Laughter]
um I hope you'll all excuse me for a
moment while I read out sponsors for
this year's Global game Jam um so our
headlining sponsors are DOT big bang and
coherence the Empower sponsors are crazy
games yahaha Google Firebase and Photon
the diversifiers of course are unity in
world global engagement center of the US
Department of State Cubs I hope I'm not
pronouncing that incorrectly UK games
one GitHub and Avatar the accessibility
fund is Autodesk Global promotion is
Intel and side effects uh products and
services uh plus music AWS for games
incredible Weber or sorry it's pronounce
Weaver uh Microsoft Xbox hyperpad
construct yo-yo games and the
promotional partners are DDM Nimble
giant geopipe richcast procedural world
and you can go to
globalgamejam.org sponsors to find out
more about all of the sponsors and
offers available to Jammers this year a
very very big thank you to every single
one of those sponsors for making this
possible and for a lot of their Outreach
work that they do as well like I know
that there are um some facets of this
that make sure that people in
communities who may not have them have
access to certain kinds of technology
that they otherwise wouldn't have access
to it's um very helpful for a lot of
people a lot of different resources that
they can offer to help people and again
a great entryway to get into Game Dev if
that's the thing that you're interested
in which I think it's pretty great
highly recommended
definitely
um somebody in the chat said rooted
phone
I'm not sure what you would mean by that
but I'm excited to see whatever that
means it's basically hacking a phone
it's getting ready
oh yeah like to an Android device of
course see that could be cool you could
have a hacking mini game yeah that's
awesome I like this idea
well I'm excited to see what comes from
it and we are going to be talking to the
global game Jam board uh coming up next
man rooted so exciting very exciting
cool to see so many people in the chat
just jumping through what they're
thinking of today too because they keep
saying things like even with the
conversation we have with all of them
but now with us too was like oh what is
this gonna be I know there's so many
options so many options it's
so Broad
um yeah very excited and yeah just kind
of picking people's brains seeing what
uh how they interpret the word
um but hello welcome
hello hi hi
so excited to be here uh would you like
to all introduce yourselves maybe
because I didn't do that last time and
definitely should have which is my bad
uh JC do you want to start with your
instructions sure
um hi I'm JC Lau I am the current
president of the board of directors for
Global game Jam Happy game Jam day
everyone
I'm Sabrina sulba I'm the vice president
of the board for Global game Jam
hello noranda Sharif I'm the secretary
I bet you were all uh very excited for
this to come out today right
yes
long time coming and I do want to give a
shout out to everyone that's worked so
hard to make this event happen so all
the event organizers the Committees um
everyone that's actually jamming like
we've had a really good turnout this
year so I'm just really excited for this
week yeah can you tell us what the
turnout is how many do we know how many
teams we have participating
um Sabrina do you have those numbers
because I do not know we have a check we
had 770 approved states
there could be one team where there are
sites that have 20 teams so it's a lot
of people they might get more than that
there are still a few sites that are
moving through the the queue so
hopefully we'll hit close to 800 yeah
over 15 000 registered already whoa whoa
that's amazing thousand registered
that's so wonderful yeah
um last year we had almost 600 was it
600 games I got made wow wow that's so
cool yeah what an awesome thing I'm
sorry I was off by times ten sorry
I was impressed by 600. I'm sorry yeah 6
000 games so it's been it's really cool
just to see so many people get involved
and make good stuff that is exciting for
everyone else to play like we do stream
about it as well and we have you know
people get prizes people learn you you
form like you form groups you make
friends so yeah it's just a really great
time
oh sorry go ahead no no I was just
adding for it to JC that also this year
especially um special because I think
most sites have been offline for the
past two years so most places have been
going
um off-site and meeting face to face for
the first time for two years since two
years yeah this is
um this is different and we've missed
this everyone missed this I bet yeah
yeah it definitely makes a huge
difference um because we have you all
here right now I just want to know I was
like what actually goes into making the
global game Jam possible I imagine this
is not an easy thing to put together and
you don't have to detail every part of
the process for me but I'd love to have
like a little bit of insight of like
what the planning for this every year
looks like
oh it starts early
we start we start very early I mean I
can speak from the the regional
organizer side so that's the team that
uh actually processes all the site
applications so we have calls with every
site organizer around the world just to
make sure they're ready to go they know
what's going on for this year to get
them approved make sure they're going to
run a great jam and we start recruiting
for that team
um in the summer and then they really
get to work in the fall as the site
applications come in so that's that's
that side of it and then there's all the
other facets as well translation
um which really ramps up in the month
before the jam just getting everything
translated and prepared since we have a
global Community yeah
uh of course creating the theme uh we
have a committee that works on on that
so if you enjoy the themes that
committee does amazing work every year
um we have the team that's running the
staff of global game Jam Tim and Charlie
and taraja who keep Global game Jam
running all year long
um
trying to think of other other things
that are happening in the background
how big is the the team overall
depends on how you define the team yeah
I guess it's it's difficult when
something's this International I suppose
and then all the volunteers and all the
work that goes into it and right
Zayn who runs our website uh that's
that's a year-long Endeavor as well yeah
sure yeah yeah it looks amazing the
website looks really really really cool
like the I love the the kind of color
themes this year it's just yeah pretty
it's gorgeous
yeah yeah because great work
yeah for anyone um
watching who may just need a reminder
that is
globalgamejam.org the jam is of course
running 30th of January 2 5th of
February
um there's an FAQ on there there's
details about sponsors games locations
um all that good stuff so you can find
out
everything you will need to to jump into
Roots how are you guys feeling about
Roots as a theme obviously we've spoken
about it a fair bit but I think it's
awesome
The Moment I Saw the the theme reveal I
just had tons of ideas buff off in my
head I felt like it's itching to just
work on ideas sketch them and maybe like
you know this this rush you get when you
see it when when the video is wrapping
up and you just can't wait to go there
and start working right away yeah
yeah yeah so I mean and that it has been
um well thought through I think for this
year to be rude so I think as you've
said during the theme reaction it can be
interpreted across different cultures
differently and you know it's it's
endless the possibilities are endless
with with roots I think
I agree
yeah I'm really excited for it just
um you know I mean the twitch chat just
kind of lit up and everything yeah oh my
God here all the ideas
I just love the fact that the theme is
something that has so many
interpretations and it's not just like
literally the word but like like when
you put that layer of like how does each
culture understand how this word works
and how what are the origins what are
the roots of the word root like you
could go with super meta um and there's
just so many possibilities with it and I
just love like you know when you see
when you get the ideas and you know
right before they have the word on the
screen you have all the like different
Inspirations for it just seeing where
all that can go and seeing how far you
can take a theme as well and I just love
seeing when you have like the you know
those like mental chains of like what
does this word mean and how does this
apply as a game concept how does this
like how do you build this into a game
system and then having a product at the
end and just like seeing that through
line through it is really exciting
related to that can you guys give us a
little bit a little insight on how
um
judging Works what's the what's the
judging process like is it is it based
on the theme or is it based on something
else like what how uh the game's
actually um judged and voted on
well we don't do that
we don't we so Global game Jam is not a
contest so we don't uh judge and say
like this this game is better than the
other part of our goal is that people
take risks and they feel comfortable and
safe uh doing things that might might
not work uh that might might be too
weird to work or maybe they're they're
reaching
um and so the the main Jam itself is not
a competition we do have you can
actually like
diversifiers uh the thing I was sort of
referring to but I guess those are
probably done by the sponsors right
oh yeah okay yeah sorry that makes
perfect sense
yeah and individual sites might have
that as well but um as an organization
to what Sabrina said it is he like we
are here to learn and Inspire so it's
not competitive it can be but it doesn't
have to be like I definitely think
that's a thing that makes it feel more
accessible and a thing that historically
I think people like about global game
Jam is that in itself it's more about
participating but I like that there are
incentives too for people to actually
focus on other certain diversifiers that
go for certain things and you can't
potentially win prizes um which I think
is very cool you don't have to so it's
kind of less pressure I think you're
kind of competing with yourself like can
I finish the game in the time allotted
how far did I get oh maybe I didn't
finish it next year I'm gonna get a
little a couple steps farther so it's
with you not necessarily against
everybody else
yeah it's basically challenging yourself
like reaching new limits to me the game
jam is trying new ideas or trying new
let's say tools that you're too afraid
to try out and yeah your everyday life
or everyday work the club the game Jam
is a space where you can try out new
things that you don't normally try out
or don't have time to try out or maybe
this is the the time that you should be
trying it out so I think this is this is
the game Jam for me
very cool yeah somebody in chat said I
like to do games in new engines during
Global game Jam which is a great idea
yeah because you can use
any engine you like
um or none in theory
um and so being able to you know try out
different things and learn different
softwares actually a very cool facet of
it as well yeah that doesn't
doesn't remember there were there was a
site that participated in that most
people pitched in and making the board
game and even some made you know these
miniature characters and we printed out
a large board and Drew on it it was fun
just connecting with people and trying
out new ideas and trying out what we
don't normally try at one year
um I don't remember what year but it was
Global game jam and I had played a game
that was uh basically a series of
documents I don't know if they use
Google Drive or not but it was a text
Adventure that linked through documents
which is really really cool and really
unusual like I love that yeah it was
like a thousand Pages like you know
those Goosebumps books yeah it's kind of
like that it was very very cool page 35
if you want yeah exactly but because it
was all digital you just linked to it
which I thought was incredibly cool and
I think works for people who maybe have
teams who don't have art experience
there's always you know options not that
you can't make your own off that always
works too so a lot of very very cool
options there um well thank you all for
for joining us and chatting to us it
seems like everybody is very excited and
I'm excited to see what everybody comes
up with do you have any closing thoughts
rest well remember it's not that right
rest well and drink well
take care of yourself and the rest of
your team yeah
um ultimately this is fun this is
supposed to be a fun event so like do
those things like rest um make sure you
are not like you know you're not
crunching that I have a whole other
conversation I could talk about about
the games industry and that but the the
whole thing here is you're here to learn
and have fun and make friends so make
sure that's your priority the game is
the consequence of that so yeah
very very good words especially to hear
from the directors really appreciate
that don't Crunch drink water and sleep
we are going to jump into a trailer now
from dot Big Bang who's one of the
sponsors this year
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
is going to join us to show us the
platform they're building dot Big Bang
it's an online game making platform
where you can make games that work on
any device and share them with a link so
look out for links in chat hopefully we
can have those come through uh welcome
Robert
hey how you doing thanks for the intro
yeah doing great it has been some
awesome music so far I hope that trailer
was great too you guys killed it as well
yeah the awesome news it took us ages to
find that track that was a fun one oh
really so so we're going to um we're
gonna do something a little bit
different today
um you know in the spirit of global game
Jam we're going to game Jam in the game
jam and so we're gonna build a game in
five minutes all right then we're gonna
put a QR code out there and a link and
you can jump into the game that we're
just building right now awesome wow so
we've got a little course laid out here
and we've got five friends in our
multiplayer game editor so I'm gonna do
a WWE style intro to everybody
so he this is uh Charles
this is a summer this is Charlie this is
Ashley and this is a voxelius so yeah so
what we're going to do is they're going
to I'm going to give them a countdown
and then they're going to just start
building so three two one go
so this is an overview of the map when
you can see
uh people are starting to select things
and so you can see in the editor the
lines going from their characters to
things yeah collecting yeah
um what's actually happening there is if
I just jump into uh the player mode so
this is my little character here
um when you end up big bang like in a
game that you can edit you can just hit
this edit button in the top left and
then you can move stuff around so I can
edit from the player camera just messing
up out with it while other people are
changing things
um and I can also you know there's a fly
Cam and there's also an orbit cam like a
normal game editor but I'm gonna have to
jump back to this overview camera
otherwise I'm gonna miss it because
they've practiced doing this in four
minutes and whoa impressive yeah so
they've got the they've got kind of the
component parts of the game over here on
this assembly stage and then they're
going to drag them in and put them in
place hopefully it won't be too
death-definingly difficult
um but yeah we've got some I hope it is
we've got some smashes and Crushers over
here we've got some
terrifying spinning blades happening
yeah I'm gonna go and jump to my
drone Cam and see what's happening so
we've got this first section of spinny
things just happened very quickly it
really did
yeah so we we spend a lot of time just
messing around building stuff and on the
streams this uh this week we've been
just chilling out and making like random
stuff but we thought today it would be
better to build something that was a bit
more like a game because sometimes
people are like well can you actually
make games or is it just like random
stuff and um you know these things have
uh scripts on them so everything in the
game editor is editable we can
we can jump back and fly over to that
stuff and just show how some of it works
so we've got like a spinny thing here we
can click the edit button and this is
actually the code editor from Visual
Studio code so all the same kind of
things that you'd imagine autocomplete
all of that is in here
um and then yeah we can zoom around by
just hitting F on things wow it's so
cool this is like a live collaborative
editor that's so neat yeah and so you
know all of the stuff in here in fact
everything the drone camera that I've
been using is just a game object and
it's being driven by in exactly the same
way as everything else so
yeah so it's coming together they're
doing a good job go build team go build
team who do you think's gonna win
uh well you know the thing is we're
going to throw the link out to the
community and as soon as we do you know
it's going to go into chat here and it's
going to go
um there's going to be a QR code on the
screen that you can scan and so I don't
know I mean our team is very good at
this kind of Parkour type thing but I
also feel like Community might have them
can underestimate the community yeah I
don't know it could be difficult okay so
it looks to me let's go back to the
silver cam I think we're actually done
so wow two things to do before we do
this I'm gonna hit I'm going to try and
get everything right I'm going to press
save
so you can save the game while it's
running
um so you know that's another cool thing
like you can edit from the player
perspective you can save the game while
it's running everything that you edit
stays
um and then I think all I need to do now
is hit Y and if you scan this QR code
wow this should turn up in the game so
let's see what happens and this this
link at the top as well should go into
stream chat so I'm going to paste that
in here I don't know if that's going to
turn up in
actual chat in the real places but I
don't know if somebody needs to paste
that into chat uh all right I'm in
okay okay so don't stand on the start
line yet let's go back down and take a
look I'm going to leave this on the
screen okay there's people turning up uh
if you are um if you're a guest you turn
up as this blue thing you don't need an
account to play so let's just give
people a couple of minutes oh oh oh look
at this
this is a bit insane
players I guess we'll find out all right
so I see the jump button yeah you can
use your number keys to emote so you can
like press some give us some hearts with
a number nine oh yeah
I just picked up one you go uh on mobile
immediately okay we'll give it another
30 seconds and then I'll give you give
us a countdown and
we're gonna see who's going to win this
game all right
let's okay I'm just gonna go now any
other controls we need to know
uh the controls are just like Run and
Jump and try and be the best all right
that's my favorite control we can do
this we're gonna be the very best
I believe in you okay so three everyone
okay everybody stand on the start line
we need like 30 000 people on the start
line okay three two one go okay okay oh
my goodness oh this is already
terrifying okay okay you've got this oh
that's bouncier than I expected yeah I
didn't expect that wait did I die oh no
I started okay let's go yeah the green
things are checkpoints when you're
running through oh thank you so I was
going to get to a checkpoint you can
hopefully respawn from that point oh no
damn who's in the lead okay I'm gonna
sacrifice my ability to win this game
not because I'm not gonna win but
because I want to get back into the
Drone cam
you can I'll get past you okay let's go
oh there's some sad people falling off
down over your edges are bouncy
okay so people uh people are struggling
with this section oh look somebody no I
got popped
okay somebody's ahead
I feel like this is a ringer this is
feeling pretty intense I also just got
popped a bit exploded all right yeah I
had made it all the way to the last one
and it popped me yeah it's it's a sad
time
this is very cool that this is something
that we can all just jump into and and
play this quickly like this without even
anyway five minutes download anything
that's incredible yeah and so all of
these pieces you know we have what's
called templates which are all version
of prefabs we've got a whole bunch of
stuff you can just drag in and mess
about with oh look here we go here's the
challenge
oh you know what there was a guess that
there was a guest at the lead but now
we've got the dev teams coming back oh
there's something up here
some of our own up here I think this
person I think this person's a ringer
they're gonna win okay okay okay so
that's the first place oh we've got a
winner already yeah well it's gonna it's
gonna yeah it's gonna show you in the
podium in a second uh and once we have
three people I believe it starts at
sudden death countdown so much okay yeah
the next checkpoint I'm almost there
okay by the um
like the teeter-totter of saw wheel
mostly of death
I believe that's the official Dev team
name yeah yeah
okay guess come on Guess come on oh oh
one of them made it here you go you can
do it
you can do it we believe in you come on
you can do it oh no both got chopped oh
here we go we made it did you make it
okay
now we got oh not again
okay we're gonna have to usually it's no
one left behind but we're going to leave
you behind
somebody else like pushed me off the
edge okay there's a there's a there's
some kind of like collaborative party
happening before the Finish Line I don't
know that this is in the spirit of
[Laughter]
come on 22 seconds so how many people
can actually play at once
did you get past this section did you
win
no no I'm miles back no let's go I'm not
doing well at all nine eight I believe
in you you can get this I don't know
that I can my friend but I appreciate
your belief in me on what's Happening
it's at the Times going back up again
it's that's not a bug why is that I
don't understand oh I think it's because
we've got three people
okay
let's jump to
the finishing area
which is over here
that was a good time
firing some celebratory
fireworks
and then let's see who who our winners
were
we've got a big oops because I failed I
also got a big oops oh man that's bad
yeah so number one is DMM
number two is a guest
number three who's this is this sink
there's a sink from our Discord
congratulations yeah sync is so much
better than games than me and I'm always
like making games beating me at but I
think we got a little we got a little
party happening we're jumping around
fairy yeah I'm in the jumpy party yeah
yeah and that's that's pretty much it
um super impressive if you want to um
use that big bang to build stuff for
Global game Jam or you know we can go
back to the go back to party mode if you
want to use that big bang to
um
build for Global game Jam we've got a
specific channel in our Discord that's
dot bigbang.com forward slash Discord
um we've got a whole bunch of example
games and getting started stuff and a
whole bunch of other things there and uh
yeah I mean the whole the whole reason
that we built this really was
um you know just tools are so slow these
days it's really frustrating sometimes
to just try and build something and by
the time you've had an idea you know
it's the times the kind of times pass
right but I think being able to just
like hit edit and edit the game yeah you
can't really go faster than that so yeah
so I think um you know that's the that's
the thing that we wanted to show today
and very very cool we went faster than I
thought we would so
yeah no that is that's awesome yeah come
and hang out on disc in our Discord join
this game and um yeah that's everything
we had to show you today
well thank you so much and thank you for
sponsoring the show
um where where can people check out
outside of the game gym where can people
check out more about dot Big Bang yeah
so you can just go to dot bigbang.com
um and right there you know you can just
build games from the front page once you
sign up
um we also have another URL which is
pretty funny called game.new and if once
you've signed up you can just type
game.new in your browser and make a game
hell yeah wonderful instantaneously
quick to make stuff I love those we do
it we do a ton of stuff in our Discord
so we do weekly art challenges every
everything in this game every single
object is made just in the browser in
our tools we've got a voxel object
Editor to make all the objects we've got
coding tools to do all the coding
um yeah and we're just in we're in
Discord like the developers you know I I
wrote a bunch of the code on the on the
project so it's uh people who actually
make games helping you out doing stuff
and uh yeah that that is the that's the
thing so dot bigbang.com forward slash
Discord and then we yeah we've got a
whole bunch of um Global game Jam
content in there but yeah I think we um
if anything we went too fast so
yeah and then I think we are going to do
a couple more streams
um in in this week we did a whole bunch
of streams on the on the kind of lead up
there
and uh yeah that's that's pretty much it
so very cool get out out thank you so
much for joining us yeah thanks so much
for having us thank you
see you later bye
that's super inspiring
yeah hi everybody
we just played a video game that was
made in five minutes it was that is
incredible yeah I was watching you and I
was like wow I'm glad no one can see how
bad I am at video games
I did not make it to the end
um in my defense I was on mobile okay
okay
[Music]
so much no you're giving me too much
credit
very very cool though I think for our
next segment we're going to jump in and
actually talk to the global game Jam
founders
I believe and have a chat with them
about everything Global game Jam if
they're ready to join us yeah and I and
I will be uh popping off so I'll see you
guys a little bit
hello
[Music]
hello everyone how are you all doing
today
very good can you hear me very good yeah
that's a nice surprise
um how are you feeling about the the
reveal how do you feel about the
response so far
super every time we had a reveal it was
always that that um excitement and we've
always had amazing things which is uh
something that uh I've been so proud of
over the years
yeah and I just want to mention
um this is something you have to be kind
of old to to get uh maybe maybe Susan or
Ian a kid back me up on this but uh
Roots was a TV show in the 80s and it
was named so obviously because it was
about the slavery history slavery in
America and one of the stars in that
show actually a bunch of stars in that
show and it ended up later being part of
Star Trek the Next Generation and so
LeVar Burton who played uh Commander
Jordan in the Forge who was the chief
engineer on Star Trek got his start from
that show uh Roots so
um a lot of connections there I did see
some people say that in the chat and I
had not heard of roots
um but that's that's an interesting one
because there's nothing stopping people
from going with the TV show as a theme
either right I guess
it could be wild it was like a mini
series about you know what happened yeah
because education in the United States
about our bad history is it what we talk
about so true yeah
it was like a an Awakening for people so
I think Roots is an amazing theme and it
additionally like everyone said there's
so many different ways you could go with
it you know and you can have a lot of
fun I could totally see a whole bunch of
uh Dungeon Crawlers too
yeah
I mean it's also today there's so much
about climate change right so this Roots
I think is very strong there and I'm a
migrant myself so I think uh about what
I'm what are your roots once you travel
should you place a new country uh what
does Roots mean uh yeah I think it's
really a strong thing you always look
like a viking no matter where you go
can't escape it very strong roots right
there
reinvading the UK
[Laughter]
so can you guys tell us now that we have
you all together a little bit about how
Global game Jam started to begin with
for anyone who's not aware
take it yeah so I was sitting in a talk
at a conference
um on a Scotland in visby and um they
had a presentation from the Nordic game
jam and I had never you know I had been
in education and I never heard of the
game Jam before and this is you know
2008 and
they made the most incredible games in
the course of 48 hours and and so I
walked up to the guys from the Nordic
game Jam afterwards and I'm like I have
this crazy idea and they all looked at
me like I was insane but then Gorham
kind of came over and said I'd like to
talk to you some more about this and we
had a conversation and it kind of
exploded then I came home from Sweden
talked to Ian and then Ian was like I'm
down and got him involved and we had our
first um you know Skype call because we
were very big on Skype then we had our
first Skype call and somehow we came up
you know we were trying to figure out
the name of of what we were going to be
and I remember we batted around a whole
bunch of things but when Global game Jam
kind of came together I think we knew
that was it like we kind of like boom we
got it and then
um you know I was kind of going blindly
at putting this all together because I
really didn't know anyone who had made a
game Jam before so I talked to the
people who had done experimental game
jam and then I used my entire network
and while using my network
um I was
on another Skype call and foad was on
the call from UC Santa Cruz and was
telling you know like oh I could help
you oh I can help you and then I
wrangled him in and we've never let him
go
yeah that's the beginning very cool and
and how long has it been running for now
well so we got together in 2008 so uh 15
years since uh we started the idea and
then
um uh you know it just has grown
exponentially year after year and it is
really thanks to the people that have
participated in the game Jam but all of
I mean I have to give the guys you know
they really kind of helped really
tighten up what the game Jam was going
to be
um
power of of just you know good hearts
and a lot of great intentions and we
figured it out somehow like we had no
idea what we were doing on trying to do
it on a global level and I were telling
Boaz oh I have no idea how we're going
to upload all those games like I had no
clue but anyway
um a short little slideshow of like
major things that have happened so we
can give you a little uh
a little
yeah it's just a really short thing but
before we start um does this short look
familiar to you fantastic
it's uh it's almost falling but you
can't see it but it's totally yellowing
and everything
yeah yeah ridiculous actually I put mine
in like a um a vacuum bag and I've had
it it's still in its pristine white I've
never worn it you should to get it
framed I have this um this God of War
Dev team shirt in a frame right here
because I was like I don't want to wear
it out I I would totally they have these
like picture frames for t-shirts that
are awesome like that seems like
something you're bold to be wearing it
to be honest I'd be like oh let's
treasure it forever
I was wearing mine for years
[Laughter]
yeah the first year we were able to send
things out
um afterwards it became impossible you
know yeah it's a lot of people
yeah so like this is just the just a
couple height I mean there's so much we
could say on this but just some
highlights uh as Susan said founded in
2008 we were part of a organization
called igda national game developers
Association everybody was really a
member of that uh to begin with we had
our first gem in 2009 it was crazy uh 50
sites uh we thought that was huge you
know it was already like the biggest
thing uh even then
um and you know I remember Susan keeping
track of everything on Microsoft Excel
and we didn't even have individual
people registration because I basically
had like three days to make uploading
and registration and stuff work and it
was just insane
um
and uh so we uh you know we did that it
went great everybody loved it got a lot
of publicity we did it again the next
year
um in 2012 we uh got out of our GDA and
we became our own independent non-profit
corporation which you talked to the uh
you talked to the uh board of directors
before that is who governs Global game
jam now as a non-profit and uh 2020 uh
we hit 118 countries and that's almost a
thousand size 900 on some odd sides and
uh almost 50 000 people and we're doing
great to get back after uh after
pandemic to the to those levels but I'm
looking forward to us eating that uh
maybe in the next year or so and
um yeah the four of us are are the
founders are really I'm kind of a late
founder but um there's so many other
people I honestly don't have time we
don't have any you know to to to name
all the names but I really want to give
a shout out to all these people
romanticonsman Joe Summers Lori cloaki
ilanka dunan Kate Edwards seven Siegel
Bruno De Paula Brian McDonald
Sierra Duran Tim Collins many others so
many others that that gave like free
time and energy to this to make it
happen and here I have a um I have a
little
um
screenshot of what that first web page
looked like like you can see that's on
my shirt right here that that uh that
logo right there it was it was Bare
Bones is is really uh understatement
um if you if you if you want to call it
that but yeah that's what it was and for
years the only entertainment we had was
uh I used to put up just um just like a
video of cats like cats displaying you
know on the front page and then that was
it you know every while everybody was uh
was uh doing game jams that's that's all
we had you know we had great production
and twitch you remember we tried to have
ggj TV where we would have you know
um it on here and then there and I mean
we really we tried gtj radio we had
Thomas Dolby on I mean like we have we
experimented with it as many ideas these
people came to us with and we tried you
know everything from ggj research to
um you know uh ggj clothes and um you
know absolutely
gem next yeah
that's right that's right we really we
wanted to be a community and Beyond us
being a community we wanted those
communities that were initiated in in
some of these places to to get back
together again
um when we started there were places
that never had any game development
before us and so you know
um we traveled to countries where I you
know spoke to the Congress of the of the
country to open up ideas and expand the
ideas for game development I mean it was
in Peru and and
um you know there was no game
development in Peru we've had we've had
crazy things happen we had
demonstrations and uprisings we during
game jams we've had what was there was a
nuclear accident at a game Jam
um
that was the second year I think yeah
wow yeah they had to evacuate a building
because there was a radioactive fire
they had to evacuate into freezing cold
and that did not stop them they just
they kept going wow that's incredible
yeah yeah if Fukushima game Jam still
exists I'm separately from the global
game chair but each year now they have a
Fukushima game Jam too yeah that's for
like a commemorate uh yes wow that's
really cool yeah but that Outreach
really is as Susan is saying one of the
joys of this uh so I remember gorm you
went to Cuba right to to get them yeah
yeah that was fantastic yeah that was
really good uh we've had people just fly
all over the place to get them involved
because you know the initial kind of uh
Outreach is really key because once like
at University or organization kind of
Buys in they kind of will not worry
about it after that but that initial one
so countries like Afghanistan that Joe
Summers really worked really hard to get
you know Iraq you know
um all these other places Egypt Zimbabwe
uh so we ended up in 118 countries
that's crazy that's a lot more than I
ever thought was gonna happen and not
only that we I mean I we've changed a
lot of people's lives I mean they they
first find their love for game
development at the game Jam or maybe
they meet their next partner at the game
Jam or their next business partner I
mean it's been a evolution of you know
lives come out of the game Jam
um friends of ours have gotten married
from the game Jam
um you know we had a game Jam baby once
somebody was so Pregnant like they were
afraid she was gonna go into labor and
she was still coding you know that's
awesome wow yeah absolutely now I'm
speaking of roots uh sorry go on go
ahead no I just want to say it I think
you know it's um it's great to see
though because when you leave
I also co-founded the noted game gym I
was quite nervous when I left that and
they're doing well and then when we left
the global game Jam you know quite a
different piece that it's it seems to me
that the local game gym is doing better
than ever you know the new team is doing
incredible work and I think that's just
really nice to see you know that this
thing living on and yeah my outside
perspective is I would totally agree
it's it seems like such a healthy
community of people who are really
really passionate and excited and it
just keeps getting bigger and it's
awesome I do think what you're doing for
involving different countries and
different people into game development
is incredible especially now I think of
of surprising positive of the pandemic
is that a lot more studios are allowing
remote work so you know if game Jam was
introduced into their country and then
that's how they learn to code or that's
what Inspire them to code it is actually
more accessible for them to get a job
uh full-time in the industry as a result
of that and that's an awesome gift to be
giving people really it's very very cool
yeah and I was going to say
um speaking of roots I wanted to quickly
talk about this book that is out the
first ever book on game jams that uh
myself and gormer co-author um I know a
lot of people Ian you have a few books
out and everything but this is my first
book so I'm really proud of it so it's
available yeah lots of really really
cool people all of these people were
deeply involved in global game Jam there
are co-authors of this
um we have some really cool things like
speaking of roots we like delved into
Roots this is the chapter Gorman I wrote
uh where did game jams come from what
was the origins you know uh we found we
like this this right here this picture
is from a from a game making event at an
educational institution like uh all the
way in the 70s
um and yeah a picture on the right is
from a train Jam a lot of you know train
Jam train Jam is a game Jam where you
actually uh you know develop the game in
a in a train and there's all kinds of
crazy places uh where people develop
game jams so
um yeah so the book talks about that and
we have some really cool
um uh information there for you if you
want to check it out and uh shout out to
all the authors who helped make this
happen a lot of you know these people
anakai's uh Johanna perkare Nia Wern so
thank you very cool like you said it's
uh we're getting a look at the roots
yeah absolutely Global game Jam very on
brand
um someone in the chat asked uh for a
link for the book is there where's the
best place for people to buy it if they
want to check it out well um I think
Googling it would work uh it's in it's
on the authors the uh the Springer
Springer nature website and also comes
up in Amazon
um we haven't made like a separate
website for it we probably will in case
people want to talk talk more or talk
about things that we could do for next
book so probably Amazon cool perfect
yeah
well thank you all for joining us any
any closing thoughts before we continue
the show
I just want to wish everyone a great Jam
I want you all to you know make sure you
sleep eat and be kind and good to one
another that's really all that we can
ask for is continue to
to build our community and keep our
reputation as Stellar as when we left it
absolutely uh but yeah good luck
everybody thank you all for joining us
jumping into the conference trailer now
I believe thank you thank you bye
foreign
[Music]
game right yeah in a fantasy world with
robots it has to have robots and the
online multiplayer
what what dude are you crazy making
multiplayer games is a hundred times
harder than single player
yeah you're right multiplayer is usually
a hundred times harder but with
coherence it's only 17 times harder only
17 that's insane hmm you mean coherence
at coherence IO right right
coherence really is the fastest way to
make multiplayer games even during a
game Jam wouldn't it be cool if you
could play your game together online hey
guys look I already got something
running wow seriously yeah just two
bucks is sinking but it's a start ah
Synergy see if you want to try it
yourself you can get more information at
coherence.io ggjj
it is a very cool trailer
yeah I love it it makes me smile I feel
that even when we start earlier in the
show I was like it's very very well done
uh welcome today
um to talk to us about coherence so
thank you is the trailer true is it
really that easy yes
I made a I made a YouTube video a week
ago or so uh showing this live I'm gonna
show it live today as well actually
great it seems to be a kind of a theme
to make things in minutes uh I love that
it's awesome yeah
yeah nice to meet you yes hello I'm
today I'm in Sweden it's almost nine
here so I'm getting ready for dinner uh
nice thank you for joining us wet and
cold thank you but it's been it's been
great watching the show and I really
enjoyed it and great talk Mary uh
earlier
so I wanted to talk to you about
coherence a little bit today and what is
it so coherence is a new multiplayer
technology uh created by game developers
so we're a bunch of game developers we
game Jam all the time and game jamming
is actually part of our culture at the
company as well and every Sprint the
whole company goes
in the game jamming mode for a week and
we make games with our latest release so
we're very excited to be part of a
global game Jam this year we're also
going to be jamming ourselves so I'm
gonna go to London we have people going
to Rome to Madrid to I think tartu in
Estonia at all sorts of locations and
yeah Gothenburg so yeah our team speaks
multiple languages obviously we're a
very distributed team uh so we're going
to be on site jamming ourselves and also
helping out uh with everything
uh and yeah um
I think coherence is the easiest way to
create a multiplayer game I'm gonna show
you uh and I'd like to see the flexible
super flexible and uh high performance
it's uh you know it's a game engine that
you can use for all sides sorts of
multiplayer games
we currently have a Unity SDK so if
you're using Unity at the game jam and
you're thinking about or maybe open to
using doing multiplayer why not try to
try out coherence and you can use it on
Windows Mac Linux you can make builds
for all these for webgl mobile VR
whatever and you can build deploy run
and scale and everything and
coherence.io is our website and feel
free to go there and uh get a free
account
uh so of course coherence is free to use
and free to develop in and so anybody
using it as a game Jam you can build
your games you can host them at
coherence you can share them you can
host webgl builds and and all sorts of
things so you might think like like the
trailer said uh is it crazy to make
multiplayer games at the game Jam well
we are a little bit crazy but I think
I think it's uh it's definitely doable
and we actually did a game Jam uh in
November in Sweden an invite only to
test things out a bit and we got a bunch
of teams coming in and making awesome
games really and all of none of them had
ever made a multiplayer game before wow
so so in 48 hours they made the very
quite elaborate games in some cases it's
amazing yeah and uh so if you don't mind
how I'm gonna share my screen yes please
I want to be looking in weird directions
but let's see if this works probably
well
can you see that just to be able to to
guide everybody through it a little bit
better so this is a link I'm gonna be
sharing uh in this private chat and I
appreciate if somebody could repost in
in the channels so this is the video
that I mentioned
um that where in five minutes we set up
everything people can also watch it as a
tutorial uh if they want and why would
you use coherence at Global gamejump I
think because it's easy and because this
is your chance to make your first
multiplayer game or maybe you've made
multiplayer games before and it was hard
and you want to see how it goes uh and I
personally think it's super cool to play
online with teammates and friends and
jams you know you might be jamming in a
hybrid site or an online only site and
then you can test things together with
your friends yeah
try out the new tech and also ah we do
realize it's you know you already have
to make a game the time is limited and
it is a little bit extra effort but I
think but only 17 times more as I say
so so we've actually created this
challenge uh where you can people can
win from a price pot of ten thousand
dollars so we're gonna be giving you
know Hardware software and stuff like
that whatever people choose uh to the
top three games submitted to it and I'm
gonna have people in the chat earlier
asking how judging works for this kind
of thing so in this instance it will be
that coherence you yourselves will be
picking winners do you have any criteria
that people can can look at or strive
towards definitely so we have a few
criteria and uh we're gonna be posting
that on our contest stage we're very
open about it so we're gonna be looking
at uh Innovative views of of multiplayer
I'm gonna be looking at General game
feel you know like uh the the coolness
factor of a game or um uh fun factor of
a game and also how completed is uh
compared to others and we give people
actually a week more uh than the game
Jam lasts the global gaming gem lasts to
if they want to do any last minute
changes or polish things up and then
submit and there's an hio Link at
coherence.io ggj where you can just
enter and submit
um and we'll be definitely helping out
throughout the coming weeks uh not weeks
days and yeah basically weeks on our
Discord on our Forum on site as I said
we'll be there in person and and helping
out
and uh well why don't we just jump
straight into unity and look at how we
can actually Network something that's
single player yeah and I have this I
have this really simple uh example here
uh we have um
um a little character and a little Cube
there and you can see the character can
move around and uh obviously in unity
you know you have uh these prefabs and
prefabs have uh the rigid bodies and
colliders and input scripts and stuff
like that I'm gonna just assume that you
have something and you've built a single
player again before and show you how to
make it multiplayer actually uh so when
you install coherence and coherence is a
simple Unity package the instructions
how to install it are very easy to
follow on our documentation page
uh you just open the coherence Hub and
the coherence Hub is kind of like the
central place where you can control
um uh the configuration of multiplayer
for your game and so first of all I want
to do
um I want to set up my scene to support
multiplayer player so in the hub I go
under scene I add a mono bridge I had a
live query I had a sample dialog see we
provide the sample dialog two different
modes rooms or worlds but we don't have
to go into details now and now my scene
is actually ready to be multiplayer but
I have to look at my character that was
moving around earlier so if I open this
uh character I see that I added a script
called coherence sync on it to it so all
I did was add this and then the prefab
itself if I open this in prefab mode
um then we'll show all these different
options for configuring multiplayer we
don't have to go into a lot of detail
but just so you know that the character
is going to be session based but it
could also be persistent so it would
remain on the server after we leave but
all I have to do is go to configure
and this character obviously has a
position a rotation so here I can just
set up all the fields I want
synchronized with the network I have
position rotation I could even
synchronize methods make them Network
commands
and then in components actually when you
know when I log into the game I have my
character but when somebody else logs in
they have their character I don't want
my movement scripts to move their
character as well so what I want to do
is I just tell coherence to disable
these scripts for the remote object and
I you know I do a classic thing with
physics I make the rigid body kinematic
and that's it and I do the same for the
CR the little crate we have there the
crate also has position rotation
um and I can just press play
and I made a build earlier I'm cheating
a little bit because we don't have so
much time we will tell it's okay
but basically you can see when I press
play I have these different regions so I
can configure you know local or or
remote servers I have a Europe server
which I'm gonna be using because I'm in
Sweden but we have a Us East U.S West
and Singapore later and all sorts of
regions so we're adding and then you can
see if I if I start the local server
I'll start it here every all of this is
included in the package I can just uh
refresh here and I can see the local
server is available I create a new room
let's say vdj theme reveal
and create and join it and now I'm in it
well of course I'm alone because
uh because nobody else has connected so
I'll just use that build I made earlier
and connect to the same room and show
you the uh synchronization so you can
see this room is here I join it and I
have these two characters synchronizing
this is how simple it is and now I can
share this build and send it to uh
anybody that's wonderful that's one fun
thing about coherence oh thank you
there's one fun thing about coherence I
wanted to show you here because it kind
of uh is related to the diversifier we
we came up with this year and uh so you
can see I'm I'm in this
in this Windows build and I'm in the
unity editor at the same time and in the
unity editor I can actually live add
stuff from the prefabs so uh as you know
somebody in the editor I can manipulate
the game world and mess things up for
for players you know like I can delete
things for them you know if you're
making a platformer you just delete the
platforms that people are jumping on and
stuff like that and this is pretty cool
because uh our diversifier is called
dungeon master
and it's just to be clear it's not
required for uh the actual uh challenge
we we I talked about earlier but it's
just a cool thing to consider like how
about you make a game where somebody one
of you is using the editor uh to
manipulate the game world and as a
dungeon master so to say
um and uh in order to make it uh super
easy for people to get started and get
familiar with the basic concepts of
coherence we have created this first
steps tutorial uh and it's a project
that you have the full source code to
I'm going to be posting the GitHub link
and and the documentation but uh how
about we all join it uh live now so
let's let's do it yeah I'll post I'll
post the link so I don't think this will
work well on mobile right now because
it's webgl built with unity
but if you have a desktop computer you
can join one of these worlds here so
um this is using a world-based system so
we will all be joining and seeing each
other
and if you're joining the Europe server
uh then you can see me as well so if I
connect here
okay I'm alone in this one because
you're coming all right I can also open
the same scene in unity
so you can see so here we have a webgl
build and you can very easily build your
game for webgl and and deploy it uh hey
and here you can you can use Q to wave a
mode you can jump around and this is
just a simple scene that is showing how
synchronization basing synchronization
Works everybody hey Mika hey Roy hey
Coley
uh and um so in this scene we we just
have the basic stuff but if we if we go
to physics
uh and uh now we have to connect again
uh here we have a bunch of crates and
it's showing a little bit different
things so all these crates are
persistent so you can see how they snap
to a different uh location when I
connect it and this is because they're
persistent and in our previous demo in
the prep week we actually moved them
around and I can pick these crates up
and uh and go around with them let me
just go to scenes and open the same
scene in uh
in the physics
so I can connect from the editor and
from webgl at the same time and and just
see the interaction happening uh Ed is
connecting from the editor
I can see these two characters and one
thing here is you know you also have
this concept of authority if I press tab
I can see what different characters have
authority over wow and Authority can be
transferred you know uh on the Fly
basically uh and another one I just
wanted to share one more
uh which is the moving platforms one and
this one is actually super fun if we're
several people because we can we can
write these uh this train uh around and
uh this scene will show people how to do
parenting coherence because you can just
you know on the Fly parent uh and uh
um and the parent to different networked
objects and you can see how smoothly
this still is even though even though
the platform is simulated uh on a
different server on a different client
than the actual character is
yeah that's very impressive yeah because
uh thank you and because uh this um and
kudos to the team by the way uh chiro
and Teo and everybody working on this uh
project really did a great job and we
have another scene which I uh which I
promise is the last one I'm gonna show
but it's very relevant to this demo and
this year's Global game Jam because the
theme is actually roots and this is the
only one that actually is a little bit
connected to it because you get to plant
flowers and ours have Roots right yeah
and so effort
so uh here you can uh you know walk
around like in the first scene but if
you press play you can you can plant the
flower and I can plant I think I we
limited it to 30 here and please don't
draw something inappropriate while we're
looking at it with the flowers you
should have said that everybody
and if we zoom in you can see oh there's
a bunch of people here thank you you can
see each of these flowers has a timer on
it oh yes timer is you know when the
timer completes then it the flower
blooms and then it will rain next time
and even if I if I disconnect from the
game the flowers are still there even
though I created them right wow and uh
and so we can we're building this world
uh that everybody can partake in also
asynchronously if if they're not there
at the same time and even the flowers
that oh I'm not in this correct scene
let's see uh
even the but it's cool to see that
people were in that one as well but you
can see these flowers now have the state
they're supposed to have wow so yeah so
it's kind of cool
um and yeah
um
thank you guys for joining this I'll be
posting the rest of the links uh
including let's just post
GitHub link to it
and the documentation
and the
documentation to coherence itself and
here we have a few of these useful
resources the docs the coherence Discord
uh I'm posting into the internal chat I
hope somebody is reposting it
uh and we also have a Channel at the in
the the this the global game Jam Discord
called coherence where our uh colleagues
uh and me included will also be paying
attention and trying to answer any
questions you might have we have this
five minute multiplayer setup video that
I shared earlier I will share it again
uh and yeah uh join us this year and
we're so excited about this uh um and uh
I'm always looking for excuses to join
Global game jam and make time for it so
this is a great excuse for us uh go to
coherence.io slash ggj uh as said uh you
have a chance uh to to win some really
nice prizes uh the diversifier uh called
dungeon master uh that is going to be
part of your drop down when you're uh
submitting is not required but could be
really cool so if you want to use the
editor uh to uh to as kind of like a
mechanic in your game that's that we'll
be very excited about that as well uh
and yeah uh thank you so much for having
me uh thank you so much for showing what
a fascinating tool it's just so great I
I wish I'd had it in grad school because
it was way too hard
so thank you so much for showing to us
and letting letting me run around and
bounce in it and just climbing there
thank you so much Johnny thank you so
much for having me and uh hope you have
a nice day
thank you and don't forget everybody to
jam and uh to register at the
globalgamegem.org see ya perfect bye
thanks so much so next step we will be
hearing from Autodesk so that is next in
our roster stick around
hi Global game champagne from Autodesk
here the 3D software company behind Maya
3ds Max and many other softwares
this year we had the privilege of
sponsoring the global game Jam
accessibility fund and I don't need to
tell you the Baseline value
accessibility has on making games
and fostering Community needless to say
I am so so happy we are able to
hopefully further lower any barriers
between people and making games this
year
I've been jamming since 2011 and looking
back on my creative career game jams
played a hugely integral role in that
Journey so good luck this 2023 Global
game Jam season
and I look forward to jamming right next
to y'all virtually
take care
everyone's so nice
Vibes are so good uh hello and welcome
who do we have joining us
would you like to introduce yourself
hello
yeah can you hear me yeah I think
there's a little bit of lag but we can
hear you
okay now can you hear me yes we can hear
you well okay hope you all are fine
sorry for Sri Lanka I mean huh
yeah so we're doing a community
Spotlight with you here today where we
just wanted to talk about your
experience with with game jam and and
how are you feeling about the theme
reveal and and what you're looking
forward to this year
uh yeah
um actually I actually in 2019 I just
participate in a competition that was in
social media so I didn't know that was
Global game Jam I just went and
participated so that time I was making
games for hobby
I'm also a teacher for game making so
awesome I just went there and without no
experience and I didn't have any
knowledge about how to make a game so in
48 in 48 hours I have to join I have to
make the game so in Sri Lanka there are
like they are in game industry most of
them are men so they didn't want a girl
to participate in their competition and
they didn't take me for their groups
like in 40. so the the organizer he
asked me to do it alone and you just do
it so then I researched in 48 hours
everything like took notes and found a
free version how to do a free trial so
then when took notes everything just cut
off my lunch breakfast everything and
did it and I won price in that that's
incredible that you've made me tear up
that's amazing basically the boys
wouldn't take you so you just learned
how to do 100 of it yourself like that's
it's amazing oh thank you I was I got a
lot of confidence in that so actually my
yeah I had a dream to make a game but I
didn't know that time there is an
industry called game industry so I just
want to make a game because I'm also a
gamer so sure
and then into after that I research
about game industry what is that is
there any place so I can go and make
games then I found a global game Jam in
the internet in in social media then I
asked the another next year like I asked
the organizer can I join without any
experience I have only made one game
they said yes you can come and then I
made the first game in global game Jam
in 2022 and there was a error in the
first stage and I made it again and it
was me so I was so happy like uh I like
I made two games without no help
um
so I got like uh and they in global game
Jam they gave me a certificate that was
like I was so happy and that is for
Innovative collaboration and creative
creativity so yeah and that was awesome
I was I love that then again I research
everything about game and I got a job to
do the quality assurance
in game Shadows yeah in LinkedIn so when
I was searching that so I researched for
that and in three days I think I have to
submit that works I that was okay
and I got experience in that so again
came to the in 2021 again I want to
become uh organizer for Global game Jam
next for kids and I have a I have a lot
like I knew I'm also teacher so I knew a
lot of kids they like games so I asked
the quest them requested them to join
and only I did it online and that was
successful and in 2023
again I want to do it again and I want
to do it hybrid like two modes from in
person and also online so I got the
opportunity this time and I'm glad to do
that and in this year 2023 uh I was
selected as a mentor in international
game developers Association so I was so
happy like now I can guide someone to
the industry how to find a job
others and now I'm making like I I am
sometimes I'm voluntary as a game making
teacher for kids
so they will get to know how to make
games
that's incredible we need more people
like you all of that is amazing
um so what is the industry like in in
Sri Lanka which is where you're from and
what do you think are some avenues for
for kids or other women to get involved
in the games industry there
um yeah women and I think
Man compared to like meals and Men
that are most of the men are in the game
industry here sure I would yeah I would
encourage women to come without like any
knowledge knowledge in game industry but
you have you uh you should have a
passion yeah and yeah you have you
should be positive and you should like
put a lot of effort to learn by yourself
then uh I can help you from my side I
know like how to make a CV how to find a
job like that I can help you and also I
can teach kids how to make games like
using scratch a kid without any
knowledge I think they can start with
the scratch
this is that phone call stretch they can
go there and unity uh yeah I think unity
and other platforms also okay
very very very cool
um so how long have you been playing
games for just out of curiosity and
what's your favorite game
my favorite game is Mario and other
games also I like other games also and
car games especially very cool
um I'm sorry I was gonna ask a similar
question I think go ahead Mac I was
going to say what kind of games are the
ones that you're creating yourself
sorry what kind of games are are you
creating
I I am oh yeah I'm creating educational
and entertainment games for kids and
adults Learners
um I just researched a lot about uh
anything a subject for example how to
protect our nature our environment and I
just research on that topic and I go
through every syllabus from small
children and for dolls and make a game a
mix every like all the lessons in that
and when you're playing that game you
will get a knowledge
very cool I have created if you want I
can share that with you I have three
games you can
that sounds awesome yeah please do yeah
if you can
um we do also have a community Spotlight
where
um you are featured on the global game
Jam website which is awesome but for
anyone who's interested in in your help
how can they actually uh reach out to
you what's the best way to do that
can reach out to me through email or
LinkedIn
very cool
um are you excited about the theme of
roots this year
yes
definitely a fun one I'm excited to see
what people come up with yeah do you
have any ideas that come to your mind
for roots
I don't I don't know really I don't know
it's no problem everybody's got time to
think about it
um
um so if we can we'll track down uh some
links to to where we can
um let people check out the stuff that
you've worked on but it's a very cool
story I definitely love the idea of if
you want to get involved in something
just learn how to do it and and do it in
your own time and you don't need to know
anything to get started because I think
the the starting part is is the really
scary part but it sounds like you were
just like nope I'm not scared I'm gonna
do it and I I absolutely love that it's
such a cool story
yes even though I had a lot of barriers
in like universities
um I want to do a degree in games so I
went from University and in that
University the particular lecture was
like harassing girls so I didn't go to
that so he like expect a lot of sexual
favors from ladies so I couldn't go
there so just drop it and I didn't know
actually what to do then I researched
from the internet and self learn
everything is self learn like then I'm
so happy now I can't teach any others
how to come to this industry incredible
it's just yeah absolutely you make me
want to be a better person that's
absolutely amazing thank you so much for
sharing
um and thank you for for all that you're
doing in Sri Lanka that's that's
absolutely awesome yeah
and I'm ready I'm very happy that I'm
now I'm an organizer in global game jam
and especially I'm doing for kids age
group uh 6 to 16. awesome
yeah and then I just told I told them
about this and they are very happy and
they they have a lot I think they are
ready to come do this event
very very very cool
um well it's it's an awesome initiative
and I love the idea of uh kids getting
involved top to bottom there are so many
kids who are clearly interested in gamed
up but don't know where to start and
yeah yeah it's definitely just an
absolutely awesome uh awesome thing to
do so
um thank you for joining us and have an
awesome
rest of you yeah thank you so much thank
you thank you have a nice time thank you
so much
thank you so much
oh my gosh what an inspiring story
I I honestly want to cry my god
um that's incredible she's made three
games and she just did it by herself
where she couldn't get help otherwise
I'm just like dude like it's just
learning from the ground up and it just
shows that like the entry point anyone
can do it there's so many resources to
get started and learn how totally yeah
and like she said I think passion is
really important once you have passion
you'll figure it out and you'll get
through it and man like that genuinely
made me really emotional I'm like oh my
God okay um so next up from our
community Spotlight we are talking to
Chrissy I'm hoping that I'm uh saying
that correctly who has four years of
experience participating and being a
coach in the global game Jam um if they
are ready to join us there you are hello
hello
can you hear me we can't hear you yes
welcome uh would you like to introduce
yourself
yeah uh I'm just busy I am from Tunisia
and
the team lead of the department the
virtual reality of montagerity and DJ
art teaching lab so
this is me and I will talk today about
the experience that I had in the global
gaming jam and the impact that I has
from since 2018 I guess yeah from 2018
until now three years of experience and
as a participant and now I found myself
in the team of the organizer of the
global gaming Jam Indonesia here in
digital
so yeah uh I can start with the
I will talk a little bit about my
experience in global gaming Jam so in
2018 I was like discovering the
university and this is this was my first
year as an University and I was like
discovering the community Stuff Etc so I
knew my teacher which is the founder of
digiart living lab she thought she told
us about the global gaming job and
creating game I was surprised how can we
as
uh as you know yeah 18 years old
creating video games that's not
impossible this is not possible so uh I
participate I have seen a lot of skills
around creating games and I was impacted
by from uh all the participants everyone
talk about some skills and he has like
each one has some skills someone's doing
music either do sketching creating 3D 3D
environment some of them is a developer
and me as a software engineering
uh I was like okay that's cool let's
create a game and let's start doing this
with other guys so yeah uh I discovered
how to create video games with the
global game jam and I was participating
from 2018 Hilton enter now and in 2000
uh
2020 I guess and with the coronavirus
Etc so I started being a coach okay so
because
we prepare the global gaming jam and
after that I discovered in digital art
living web they bring kids to impact
them to the global game Jam next it was
amazing so in the global gaming Jam in
this year we bring kids to see how the
production stuff going and how they
create people creating sketches other
developing the projects some of them
creating uh the the environment and we
coach them and we prepare them to the
global game Jam next okay so yeah
basically this is the experience that I
had in the global gaming jam and also
the fact that you impacting kids are
impacting uh people around you and from
the industry from any field it's amazing
so also we bring it's my medicines
we bring the doctors
teachers researchers to to see how they
can create a video game for social
impact
and that will be
helpful in in the industry
so basically the experience that I had
from the global gaming jam and we as the
digital trading web it's like tradition
and our structure to participate and to
bring people to discover the world to of
creating a video game so this is our
main objective we used games for the
social impact for
advertisement for for creating some
project for for teaching for schools and
for for the University just to tell them
that to create a video game it's not
something impossible so you have you
need some skills to have
social social
impact maybe you are just a doctor who
have the idea of creating a video game
for example for your patients and I
don't know so this is this is the idea
and we as this try to guide them to how
to create a gamified video game for
their I don't know they are at the same
process or I don't know so this is the
main objective of our instruction
so yeah and uh the social impact uh
things and how we can impact people made
us like creating a lot of program during
uh creating video games and creating now
we have the concept of the metaverse so
we're creating some games using the
metaverse ETC and I will be happy to
share with you our last program that we
are doing right now which is the Africa
metabor so if I have the permission to
share with you the website so
I will share I will share the link here
I think in the comment section or I can
paste it and directly and yeah if you
paste it yeah perfect and then we can
get that link out to all of our streams
my my I will share my screen to show you
the website so this is the Africa meta
verse it's totally free program for for
young parents
for all the Africa not only for Tunisia
so this is the big impact now we are
working on and we have like 300 talents
around this program to produce their
prototype of video game during the
storytelling of Africa so we in Africa
we have a lot of Storytelling a lot of
Amazing Stories each country has their
own studies so we are now start to
produce the metaverse who will give you
the opportunity to see
all the African storytellings together
with a lot of programs so I invite
everyone from the global gaming Jam from
the community around this program Global
gaming jump you can see uh
you can see and produce your game you
can learn you can have all the ideas
about creating a video game and this
year at the theme I was like surprised
about roots oh my God I was like
thinking and from now how we can produce
this word to a video game so I will try
to implement it into this program the
Africa metaverse tribe I I
invite you guys
also to see the final result I think in
in in
three uh in three months in three months
I guess so here we have all the
necessary informations to know about
this program because we are supported by
epic games Mega grants and we will give
you like the metaverse that everyone who
now waited for not maybe it would be
inspiring for other countries I don't
know but here we have like the first
step to see Africa producing their
metaverse and producing the video games
so uh yeah and also here uh for This
Global game Jam I invite you guys we
have a digiart living lab uh YouTube
channel we will see here all uh the
project during this theme which is roots
and the global gamer Jam so I invite you
guys to see the what will Africa or
Tunisia and DJ art Disney Club can
provide for kids and people uh
the opportunities that everyone will
have to see how can Africa create video
games so basically
this is us this is uh what we do I'm so
happy to be one of the team of organizer
in the global game Jam here in Tunisia
with the digital art building club by
the first 3D School in Africa which is
3D net info so I I'm glad that I am one
of their team I'm glad that I am here
with you guys with the proper game Jam
managers and I'm happy to share my
experience with the with all the
community that uh that they are now see
us in twitch or in YouTube channel so
thank you guys for for doing this for
for the community thank you guys for
give us the opportunity to discover our
skills and discover our patients because
now I am very reality developer and
modularity developer but I started
creating the video game to understand
how the industry it's work so yeah
that's basically this is it no thank you
what you've done here is awesome you
thought something that inspired you and
made it accessible to more people and
and kids and I wanted to ask what's
what's it been like transitioning from
somebody who participated in game James
to being a coach has that been a weird
experience
share your knowledge to share your
experience with all the the community
it's something like it's more important
than me creating a video games so but
someone with your experience with your
knowledge to share with them all the
resources that you use to to learn how
to create a video game and you see how
happy they are so this is the most
important thing and this is what made
you the best
a person that you are now so totally
I love coaching I love teaching I love
to share my knowledge for the community
uh also I'm coaching and teaching kids
to participating in the global gaming
jam and we are a team now in the digital
art living lab all of them have
different skills we go try to give them
the opportunity to participate and to
make their own games now we have like we
have a lot of uh I remember in 2018 I
see the kids who's asking us how what we
are doing what we are producing and now
those kids is
capable to join the global gamer not
next but now they grow up now if they
can participate and I am so excited to
see uh their production their their team
their final result in This Global game
jump so we discovered them as teenagers
they can't participate in the global
game Jam but they have the possibility
to participate in the global game exam
next so now they will participate in the
global game jam and
where I can't wait for the next week
actually so yeah
uh to see to give them the team and I'm
maybe they are here uh watching
somewhere but I think they will be like
excited to participate and to share with
them the knowledge and uh how to create
video game with the new participating I
don't know so there is a lot of
different people absolutely I feel like
kids are so creative and and they can
come up with different things in and
draw from experiences so to see how kids
interpret roots and want to create a
game from it it's going to be different
than how we do so
they give us the idea to produce our
video game so I think I remember
19 I remember that one kid that inspired
us to create this game which is uh
around the people family Etc he gave us
the idea and we put his name in our
presentation and in our demo so we have
like we we I think this this guy will
participate this year and I will be
happy to catch them technically because
he gave us the idea now we should give
him back how awesome is video game so
yeah very very cool
yeah well uh thank you so much for
joining us thank you for all of your
work it sounds incredible and I'm really
really excited to see what comes out of
it um so much yeah have an awesome week
see you guys thank you goodbye
Jam guys and see you next time goodbye
bye
um before we jump into our next segment
again another incredible person
everyone's so this is giving me more
faith in humanity
[Laughter]
um I just wanted to uh do a quick read
of the sponsors for this year's Global
game Jam our headline is uh dot big bang
and coherents who were already sore a
little bit from and were incredibly
impressive
um the empowers uh crazy games yahaha
Google Firebase and Photon I
diversifiers are from unity in world
global engagement center of the US
Department of State cubes UK games fun
GitHub and Avatar and the accessibility
fund is Autodesk Global promotion is
Intel and side effects products or
services are plus music AWS for games in
credit build Weaver Microsoft Xbox
hyperpad construct any yoyo games and
promotional partners are DDM Nimble
Giant geopipe richcast and procedural
worlds and now I believe
we are jumping into a video there's
another Community Spotlight from Saudi
Arabia
welcome to the 2023 Global game Jam all
the way from Saudi Arabia my name is
Michelle abuelada and I have been the
site organizer for Jeddah for the last
six years including 2023 and I have the
absolute privilege of being the regional
organizer for this year as for GCC
countries and Southwest Asia in Saudi
Arabia we are witnessing the huge rise
of the gaming industry however before
the existing of that we had the many
amazing talented and exceptional
individuals who led us to reach this
point so a few numbers from my side last
year as of global game Jam 2023 we had
nine cities participating from Saudi
Arabia alone with the total of 79 games
as an outcome for this year of 2023 we
have 10
cities participating and I cannot wait
to show you what they have for this year
as the jam date approaches I just wanted
to remind you that making history within
48 Hours requires for you to sleep eat
and hydrate very well don't forget also
to have tons of funds and meet a lot of
people
I wanted to show you some of the games
we have in Saudi from local devs and
without further Ado hello world this is
global game Jam Saudi and see you next
week
[Music]
foreign
oh that was so cool
seeing all the games the colors the
music oh it's just fantastic
um so obviously that was a wonderful
Community Spotlight and we are now
having another Community Spotlight um
this time from the Netherlands and we
are going to hello
um
great how are you doing um could you
please tell us all about you tell us
your day and what you're working on tell
us what we're about to look at uh so I'm
from TU Game Dev we had a student team
based the Technical University of einco
one but our community is open to all
game developers in the Netherlands and
especially University students uh I
think we're going to have our Discord
link pop in the chat in a minute uh if
you're interested in the Netherlands
that is interested in the game
development uh you're welcome to join
our Discord and welcome to join up any
of our events uh in order to introduce
our community I believe we created the
video and if you could watch that that
would be really good absolutely
absolutely yep wonderful thank you so
much
oh didn't see there hi everyone my name
is ongun and I'm a third year computer
science student here at the end of
Universe of technology and I'm a team
leader of to you at gamedev we are a
student team focused on video game
development and our team has members
from a wide range of disciplines such as
psychology and Technology industrial
design and computer science
our goal is to bring together students
passionate about making games and give
them a tools to realize their vision and
learn about the industry we achieve this
by organizing different learning
experiences crafted with the students
leaders in mind it is really important
to us that suicide professional
opportunities for professional
development
some of the things we organize include
game their teams which are either
projects where teams skilled they
learned to develop their own game or
game gems like this one globalganger in
2023 and lectures from industry
professionals and so on
this is a very special year for us
because it is our first time ever
hosting a global game Jam site but we
really believe that as a community ready
to take on this challenge
our members are more than ready ever
to work on different challenges whether
these are personal or technical broaden
their horizons with working and
interacting with other Jammers and most
importantly develop some games and have
fun
we hope that this year's Global game Jam
is the starting of something very
exciting and not only for two Game Dev
but for all game developers in eindon
and all your students in Netherlands we
are not only here to talk about a
community but we also want to show games
we have developed here are some games
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the Netherlands is an increasingly aging
book
hi it's me again we hope you enjoyed the
Showcase
we believe that the gaming industry is
one of the most exciting and fast-paced
industries out there and we are honored
to be a part of it
we are currently creating high quality
games that aren't only fun to play but
also push the boundaries of what is
possible
thank you for your time and hope to see
you soon
it's wonderful to see so many students
create such awesome games yeah that's so
great yeah thank you so much for sharing
oh I love these Community spotlights
it's so great to see what all the Ever
all of these people coming together to
create such different things but so and
they all look fun I want to play it was
a couple I was like oh it's that one
I was very leaning in it was great
uh thank you for allow us to be here and
we would like to thank our video manager
Thomas Seger uh for helping us with
everything and thank you so for everyone
the global game Jam team for working
it's now three and a half hours so good
luck with the rest of the team
thank you thanks so much for being here
okay and next up uh we have another
Community Spotlight which is awesome
always
this time we will be talking to Mika
from uh Finland uh he's the co-founder
and developer of boomcorp hi welcome wow
Global games I'm hello Mary hello Mac
and I guess I'm gonna start with thank
you thank you team and thank you
everyone who mentioned it's at least
gonna be long so that's gonna be like it
first start but yeah my name is
uh developer and co-founder at Boomco
Finland and a big game Jam Enthusiast so
this is my pardon for me uh I I started
my game Champs in 2010 uh with Finnish
game Champs which is also part of the
global games and family and Phoenix game
Jam is happening this year as well but
we are doing a little bit of our own
thing or we're gonna stay in the weekend
style so we're gonna do our game champ
but it's gonna be
uh basically starting from next week's
Friday so this was uh kind of a really
cool for that another also like puts
people in two camps because like some of
the people uh participated uh this event
as well but a lot of them are also uh
trying now to avoid hearing the theme of
The Jam
like a reveal of the the mid it is a
nice like event that I'm really glad I
got to participate it what made me think
like should I like close my ears and
pretend that I didn't hear it or what do
I do but uh no I was just about to ask
your reaction on the theme and let's dig
into the theme and I'm like
I love hearing like how the team come
off and like I I think I joined through
tweets uh chat like most of the time and
of course everything what happened on
the screen and also looking forward to
rest of the uh countries coming up so
I'm trying to keep mine at the damage
minutes
and a little bit more about champ
history or the Finnish games how it
started or I heard that people were like
Gathering up for a weekend to try and
make a game which sounded like crazy in
many ways yeah what about to think about
it so my first game gem actually started
by me just going their look like what's
happening here
and it was kind of like magic because
back then I didn't really know what it
is what is capable to do in what kind of
a time and definitely the weekend time
frame sounded like uh not doable land
Madness in many ways
um but it happens and the structure the
48 Hours was also something that uh
like worked really well and it's
something that has been going on like
ever since uh here in Finland and in
many places so I think 48-hour Champs
are the Champs I most participated in
I've lost count but there's been over 40
uh game Champs most in Finland but then
also around the world and I guess I can
give some shout outs or I figured I
might some of the gems are still going
and some of the Champs have been
something that happened maybe only once
and then uh they are more like they may
have been or may not have happened yeah
if I add more links
um
yeah from the channel I guess I shared
them like boom core finish games yeah
that's a good one because Fitness games
I'm linked through that if you are
interested we started doing uh our jams
in hybrid since the 2020 right and our
platform has also been tweets and
discords and Phoenix game Jam is not
only one site we have uh
I think I'm losing count of those as
well but I'm gonna say over 10 sites
around the Finland and we all work uh
kind of like from the one Discord
Channel and one tweets Channel or at
least last year those were the main
channels I'm not completely sure what's
gonna happen because I never been uh the
organizer or I never take the title of
organizer I just come and see what's up
have a good time and then like
being doing that again and again
has anything surprised you about pulling
all this together and all these people
together yeah you know now that you've
been to every you're kind of the jam
expert at this point so
foreign
like surprises me in many ways uh Global
game gem is special uh in a sense that
they try to make the network like grow
go around the world and I think they
succeeded like really well uh my most
and and it's also interesting to see how
people have it they all have their
different kind of way of like
participating the global game jump uh in
Phoenix games most of the time we were
also just interested seeing the theme
and seeing the video pre-recorded videos
based on the theme or what we're playing
it uh on the team uh announcement or
usually before Kobe times it was like a
web page that was updated and there
there was the videos
ready for you uh and in Finland yeah we
always at least hear the theme probably
not at the same time that it's announced
it's usually based on our games that we
play at the start of the jam or everyone
who came to the champ site we first
started doing little like workshops and
uh kind of games where we got a little
bit uh no no or learned to know each
other a bit or because in the early days
I didn't like I knew few friends uh who
invited me there but through the years
I've been starting to know more people
or the Chama events in Finland for me
are like a part like go see Hello old
friends and then Parts seeing the new
people coming in and it seems like uh
there's always new people coming in or
these gems are growing and the concept
uh Jam is really good to kind of
challenge you and you can also pick the
aspect of how you're gonna challenge
yourself is it gonna be that you wanna
uh try something new tech wise or is it
just that you are like challenging
yourself socially or for me uh I think
in recent jams I've been trying to
challenge myself more uh Team wise and
Technology wise like doing these hybrid
things and also finding people who I may
have not worked before or most of my 40
game Champs I have had uh people with me
who we've been making games for a long
time and boom Corp is also built through
people who I had plenty of Champs before
actually starting do you uh have like
any like big challenges that arose in
past game jams that you were able to
like problem solve and get through like
what's the biggest one that comes to
mind
challenge uh since the game Champs are
successive in a sense it's up to you
like what do you put up as the like uh
challenge level I guess sure
but if I go through like different
approaches I've seen uh when I've been
mentoring game Champs I usually always
say that if uh
uh because some sometimes when you start
making games it's really common
especially if you're a player you know
games you have plenty of ideas in your
head and you might build an concept that
it's just way too big uh to do in the
time frame that's set for the champ and
that is completely okay and I think
that's also part of the jam experience
and when I'm being mentoring in schools
uh where there has been more like visual
practices of making stuff where it's not
possible maybe to make the interactive
experience I've actually try to get
people to make uh still maybe a
presentation of the game a concept of
the game that will be watched then at
the end of the jam or in Phoenix game
jams there are two like key moments or
some special moments that I really enjoy
it's always like the starting day and
then uh the finishing uh
because we always have this stage
presentations of their like final
products and at the same kind in the
start but in the starting day we
actually do game pitches so people when
we have had all the games uh brainstorms
around the theme then we they uh I think
it's three minutes or it might be even
shorter depends on who's running it
short pictures for everyone and then we
see like do which ideas get teams and
what happens with them and that's
usually the exciting starting moment and
then exciting final moment seeing then
people coming up and saying like what
was the challenge they took on Andrea
what game of it and it's usually really
fun as well or like game gems are these
smaller Creations that are most of them
done kind of for those magical small
moments which also makes me a little bit
sad because there's so much stuff that
kind of like uh gets in the history of
my video is the best like game Champs uh
that have any kind of video recording of
the thing that they made uh usually
lasts the longest like dick wise like
dicks get dick gets old it might be uh
impossible even if you work with a
common engines like Unity like if you if
we get enough versions up ahead I think
they're like champ games stop working at
some point
but either have been through the years
something that uh is what I would
recommend for documenting the final Yeah
final thing
what do you think makes a good theme as
well I feel like that it's so the idea
of coming up with the theme is so broad
so what in your experience really really
kind of helps both root but kind of let
every root but also let everybody kind
of off the leash a little bit to really
Flex their creativity in ludum there's
there's a voting system ludum there is I
think a jam that has been going they
they have the only title of ongoing
champ that might be older than the
global game or this must be more but uh
in my knowledge loot them there
has the same concept and they do choose
a theme by voting different things
but uh it's just a suggestion like uh I
I don't think it needs to be perfect and
there's no such thing as a perfect theme
so right whoever like makes whatever I
think it's fun and cool wonderful uh
from theme announcement I remember like
in in Finland we always watch the whole
program uh but I was once mentoring in
art school in Hawaii for Israel uh and
that was slightly different as well
because they have weak like one day
ahead or behind let's see Sunday is like
their first day of the week so their jam
happened on Thursday Friday Saturday so
one day beforehand the thing so the
things were like they got a early link
before the Like official announcement
oh okay gotcha that was nice but also
like the mine said that we had they are
like I remember it was a teacher who
actually skipped the videos just to the
team okay this is the team let's go okay
well I can see like
different things and also here uh funny
seeing like when the team was announced
like you you kind of heard it that they
were like developers who ran right away
after hearing their team to work around
something or if like people like really
like wait for that moment and take it as
a maybe like this speed run in a sense
which is also a fun way to challenge
yourself like that's what kind of what
you have to do when you work with the
like short time frames
yeah I mean it's hyper concentrated it
is just like as fast and as creative as
you can be and as collaborative
absolutely oh yeah that's going to be
key yeah
Yeah the more I've been getting older I
noticed at least I do that kind of an uh
or nowadays I look for laser in my
chance so in here I also like that I got
the theme now and I can think about the
charm thing for now six days and then
I'm also looking forward like a hybrid
and live event that's going to happen
here in Finland yeah yeah
[Music]
and okay one more shout out to uh games
now all I linked that sometime before
because in all the university it's uh
the greatest or they brand themselves
well it's a really good University here
in Finland and they have a games program
going on and past games now is uh I
think they are on their eighth season or
episode or how you want to call it and
they've been making this program now
like open for everyone like usually
University programs are something that
are really closed but although it's
producing material that is comparable to
the uh the game conference in San
Francisco and documenting it also in
video formats and then they have also
game Champs running with each episode
and this current episode is also
currently going on episode 8 and here
they are talking about uh like the new
AI art and the game Jam uh challenges
you to use or explore these AI tools
like what they are what to do with them
and I think they could pick really good
topics like they pick one topic for each
episode or season
which they then explore with the people
who we invite uh making uh do some kind
of presentation and slides here in
Finland we record them and they like
come to the games now program so
anywhere around the world check out
games now although because it's cool but
we don't because it's not commercial
it's something that we produce only with
like kind of our taxpayer money and it's
part of the school program but we
learned that sharing is something that
usually brings more value to the things
absolutely games now people who run the
games now are also people who started
the Finnish game Champ here in Finland
shout out to uh Ultima and colic Park is
uh her partner I guess organizing it and
many more people once again I I should
not start naming because
45 minutes later yeah I completely
understand well thank you so much
yeah yeah this this was so great Mika
thank you so much for for talking to us
about boomcorp and game jams and themes
and just everything that uh you know is
getting everybody hyped for our Jam
right now this was this was wonderful it
was great to have you on thanks so much
oh you're still gonna be the final uh
event or another stream at the end of
like uh this week
yes okay
I'm not is there it's I'm pretty sure
I'm 99 sure but um I'm gonna let the
global game Jam folks uh chime in in the
comments yeah
on the chat if there will be a closing
event yeah yeah and share share links
and such so that we can we can all
access
this is
thank you thank you
so uh we are we are now going to hear
from one of our sponsors Intel Intel
believes in empowering creators with the
tools and systems that they need to
create mind-blowing games and
experiences join the Intel Game Dev
program and learn how Intel collaborates
with leading game and game engine
developers to enable great new
experiences go to game.intel.com us for
more information Intel will be giving
free and you see 12 Extreme Dragon
Canyon systems to five lucky Jammers uh
in the global game Jam giveaway be sure
to sign up by February 3rd using the
link on
globalgamejam.org sponsors for a chance
to win a dragon Canyon oh my goodness do
that that's so exciting that is exciting
yeah and now we will be sliding into a
video from Intel thank you
my third humor my name is Reagan and I'm
helping the Intel's gaming and Creator
team in collaboration with global gaming
Jam 2023 Intel will use an empowering
creators with the tools and systems that
they need to create exceptional games
and experiences this year we're
contributing over 15 Nook Dragon Canyons
to jam sites across the world to use
during the gym with the power of 12th
gen Intel core processors and the
discrete graphics cards of your choice
Dragon Canyon will exceed your
performance expectations packed with the
latest technology before its available
today Dragon Canyon delivers a
mind-blowing gaming content creation and
media viewing experience like no other
also five lucky Jammers will get the
chance to win enough Dragon canyon
system and our Nook game Jam giveaway be
sure to sign up
to win Enough by submitting you and your
site's information so that we can
contact you during and after the jam you
can find the sign up
on the sponsors page on the global game
Jam website under Intel make sure you
submit by February the 3rd I can't wait
to see all the cool games you make
wow that was really nice of Intel
thanks Intel no that's so exciting oh I
love uh I hope everybody signs up I am
wishing you all luck in uh being one of
the lucky five
awesome we are now moving into another
Community Spotlight so exciting uh this
time we are talking to folks from our
community in Switzerland
hello hello hey how are you this is fine
thank you you too yes it's a long it's a
long stream for you isn't it
I got my water I got a very nice candle
burning we'll be all right so please
tell us all about yourself tell us about
the community we're so excited to get to
talk to you
um yeah my name is
I'm at the moment working for the
Lucerne University of applied art of
applied sciences and arts sorry it's a
long name in English and in German it's
much easier
and I I calculated that this year is
probably the 10th uh game Jam that I
organize and it's the 12th I'm I'm part
of and I yeah that's a long time no
and I actually wanted to talk a little
bit about I mean
um Switzerland Switzerland's game
they've seen isn't as big as it could be
or as most people believe and for me it
was like the game Jam was one part where
I started to do community work because
it was like we had the global game jam
it was in 2011 I was in the global game
Jam
um and it was like this feeling of
having other people to to to talk to to
jam with that actually made me and the
colleague start our own Community with
monthly meetings and starting to
actually go and organize the game gems
and help organize the game jams
your first Global game Jam was in 2011
is that right did I have that right yeah
yeah that kind of launched uh you know
creating this community in Switzerland
as well yes yeah exactly it was like
um I I even I I wasn't working on games
in Germany and there were meetings like
400 people and then I came to
Switzerland and I was trying to find
anything I couldn't find anything and
and just because I knew actually I
didn't know the game Jam I didn't get
that one but I knew the organized and he
was like hey we are doing a game Jam
aren't you doing games and I was like
hey write me in I'm coming and I was
like for the first time not for the
first time but it was like a bigger
meeting meeting other people uh and
doing games and we are still friends
from this group of people who I did my
first game jam with very cool that's
phenomenal and nowadays we are actually
working together and that's so cool
oh that's great too that's so that's so
exciting um what do you feel like has
changed in the you know you've been
doing this for many years now and
organizing all these people what has
anything shifted in that time
it has it's it's a little bit I mean it
it got a lot bigger in the beginning I
mean not not only in Switzerland but
also in uh in in general the global game
jam it got more like um Polished in the
beginning sure we had like this four
hours upload times and stuff like this
and uh it was it was a little bit rough
around the edges and nowadays it's this
this Global phenomenon and it's so many
people and it's really cool but I think
in the heart it's still the same it's
like people meeting and just doing stuff
and uh yeah it's just come come and see
and if you like it stay and make
something and yeah don't be afraid we
can help you it's mostly like this thing
because it's a community it's like
um even if you'd have no idea what
you're doing and even if you have no
idea if game making games is for you or
if you have no idea how to start come
and start with us because because we can
help you so to figure it out
yeah that's such a great message I feel
like creating a game can be so
intimidating for so many people if
you're not a strong coder if you haven't
you know messed around in unity before
it can be really hard to get started
without yeah
it it is and I had people like uh there
was this one person who was like um I'm
just drawing stuff and even not throwing
digitally actually I'm drawing with my
pencil and I was like look come and we
will see and and she was like coming and
then I I even got my scanner from home
and we scanned her her images because
she couldn't do anything digitally and
we scanned her images and they helped
them doing that and next year she came
with a tablet and was like look I have a
lot of time to do it digitally myself
and I was so proud of her and she came
back yes she came back and I was like I
was having so much fun to see all my
drawings come to life and she was really
cool with character she could draw
really cool characters and it was really
fun and
um yeah that that was really we had so
many different people doing different
things like
one one group came with arduinos and
there was one person coming with a 3D
printer and printing stuff and it was
like like people doing whatever
oh that's so inspiring what a huge
impact it had on her and on so many
people that yeah great to hear do you
feel like most of the people that you're
getting in uh at the gym at any of these
community events are they solo
developers a lot of the time and this is
their first time working on a Dev team
or is it just even broader than that
it's it's it's even broader than that I
mean we have a lot of solo developers
because especially in Switzerland there
is lots of people doing it solo because
there is very few game companies and the
the biggest I think is 30 people and
they are mostly doing other things too
because there is no still the
professional level in Switzerland is not
uh good for big companies
um so we have a lot of solo developers
but we have also a lot of people coming
like programmers who are like
um yeah I'm doing software in my my main
job but I always dreamed of making a
game and you know like this is my my
time of the year where I can make a game
and and I have people like coming every
year for for years now who just you know
like they have their job and they have
their life and they have the family and
they was they are like this is the three
days I do this thing for me yeah yeah
that's so great responding I'm
monitoring the chat as well um as you're
speaking and I just wanted to say you
know the the line between Gamers and
game developers is a lot thinner than I
think we realize and and everything
you're saying about this community in
Switzerland really illustrates that is
that if you have this love for games you
have skills you don't even know yet that
can really be applied to creating here
and that that's what you all are
building there and inspiring people to
use those skills to create something
they love Yeah and we all also we are
open for everybody I say also the
community I I found it that my my friend
was like it's called game space and it's
still going on this year we started
again with having meetings or they
started again because uh three four
years ago I I gave it to my friend who
is now doing it because I didn't have
the time anymore I started working at
University and I couldn't do the event
anymore and my friends were like hey
then we are doing it now so I was really
happy for that and it's it's really it's
it's cool to have this this community
and it's cool to do that stuff and I
also I want to encourage people for for
instance our site last year we had just
five people because it was Kobe and
people were like ah I don't want to come
and and maybe not and I only have five
people and I was like okay let's do it
for five people actually I had the
registration only four people uh three
people were like okay we are coming one
person was like I don't know if I can
come and one person was like more or
less a surprise guest so we had just
five people and it was like okay let's
do it anyway yeah this year again I have
around 30 people so it's it's like oh my
goodness yeah just open open the doors
and maybe people come sometimes people
don't come but if you don't open it the
next year too yeah it's maybe you know
like that's also with game space in the
beginning people were telling us hey
nobody is coming and at the beginning
nobody came and I was sitting alone with
my friend there but it was like the door
is open and nowadays it's it's a it's a
driving Community with a Discord and
meetings and we have Barbecues in the
summer and stuff like this that's so fun
it really does feel like a community
event and everyone is coming together
and bringing their skills to the table
to create games yeah yeah that and it's
cool that
um also this this this inspired some
people to go from I'm doing a game in my
spare time to I'm doing a game
professionally because hey you guys find
think it's cool so I I didn't think that
was a you know like I I didn't know that
people would like that game so I'm going
to make that game because people like it
and I'm very proud of these people who
were like
jumping in and doing it
and the rest of the community who who
actually we we all are like we all know
each other and we are all like
um you know everybody chimes in and
everybody helps and and I mean in the
beginning I didn't have money for
Community for the community events it
was like somebody gave me their room
they had for meetings for another
um community and I was like uh buying
drinks and I was like look people pay if
you can and yeah hopefully I break even
with the drinks but you know like come
and if you can't pay because you're a
student then okay you don't and and it
worked out because people were like
giving me money for the drinks and
um we could somehow manage it to to to
do
that is so inspiring it's been such a
delight to talk to you about building
this community and bringing all these
people together over this shared love
and um
that it's so it's also just fascinating
how how a community continues to thrive
obviously like you were saying we've all
been through a lot of change in the last
few years but to see to see this
community is still together and still
talking to each other and it's still
really strong yeah it's just it's
phenomenal it's wonderful very nice
behind you is there any links yet
um it's um
uh game Space it's game Space Point ch
um do I write it in the yeah yeah if you
write it in this chat we'll have our
mods uh thrown in the appropriate uh
Twitch in YouTube dreams right right
wrong don't take that one
okay okay
yeah okay now
uh there is also a Discord server
um so you can everything is linked there
Twitter Discord Facebook and I mean it
for me for me a lot of of
um Saving Grace was that that things
like Twitter work
getting big and I could like do my my
marketing without having to pay anybody
anything so but um social media was
really important
yeah and keeping that Community together
again like through all of these
different changes we've all been through
and um you know especially meeting
meeting people here as well in the
global game jam and being able to stay
connected over time yeah yeah yeah and
and also I mean I think I think it's so
cool to to see
um the worldwide impact all this has the
global the global how many I mean this
community spotlights the how Global it
really is and for how many people this
is this is a really it's like uh a
really important part of their year I
always say please uh last last weekend
in January and actually the last half of
January don't
I I'm Global game Jam I'm not doing
anything else
um yeah don't bother me I'm working on
this right yeah I have things to do I
have yeah so you have games to make
yeah and it's it's really cool to see
how many people I mean for how many
people it's it's really this this
highlight of the year
yeah absolutely yeah wonderful thank you
so much again for your time thank you
for talking to us thank you for I mean
really inspiring us again I just I love
hearing about these communities coming
together especially as you said where
it's not always easy to meet other
developers outside of certain hubs and
so this is so great to hear about how
people do anyway and how we can we can
all get together to make games so thank
you again for being here
thank you for listening and thank you to
all the other community people telling
about their communities too yeah
wonderful have a nice evening thank you
bye
wonderful oh oh I love talking to
everybody this is that is so inspiring
and I love everything she said about how
you don't need to know everything about
making games to start making games is
just you know I think it's one of the
biggest barriers
um to development and it doesn't have to
be so if you like games you can figure
it out people will teach you their tools
and websites and things to help you
along the way so you're not alone ever
yeah and if you're not good at
everything that's okay because nobody is
as a true one is yeah lean on each other
a bit yeah next up we have our community
Spotlight this time from the UK um and
that is already pre-recorded so we are
going to go into another video thank you
so much
uh welcome to 2023 my name is Adam uh
I'm one of the game Jam sites over in
the UK one of the hosts at uh game day
of London uh we I was one of the biggest
sites here in the UK and I'm super
excited to be taking part in global game
Jam 2023 uh because this is actually my
10th Global game Jam so that's a Whole
Decade of global game jams for me which
uh you know I'm a huge fan of game jams
I've been doing them it was basically
one of the first things I did when I
sort of started working in video video
games uh as a student getting really
excited about and making the most basic
game that I could
um and then got overly ambitious over
game jamfons and they keep not making
games but we'll ignore that for the time
being
um today I wanted to take a take a
moment out from uh this fantastic event
uh and talk about uh neurodiversity in
game and the reason I want to talk about
that is uh because this is my first uh
game Jam uh since I was diagnosed with
ADHD last year
um so what I've found over the last kind
of year is that it's really important to
take into account that the people around
you are not you so think like you they
don't they don't have lived with the
things that you've lived with they work
in different ways
and we all know this because people
around us might not be the same
discipline or they may not be from the
same country or they may not even the
same city and all this can play into
effect how we approach stuff and and
neurodiversity and neurodivergence is
another aspect to this so this year one
of the things I want you to think about
with this amazing theme uh and this
another fantastic opportunity to make
some really cool and interesting and
novel game is about how you could
approach making games that is inclusive
that is open that is accessible that
allows the people around you to work
with you to make the best that you can
fortunately there's some really easy
ways to do that
um the key one is going to be and it's
it's a skill wheel though it's
communication big shock right
um think about the people around you as
people who they want to help they want
to get involved they want to make
something cool but they may not have the
best ways of being able to explain that
to you or and you may not have the best
ways of explaining it to them it you
know sometimes it's language barriers
sometimes it's colloquialism sometimes
it's ways that you express yourself are
different to the ways that other people
Express themselves and you don't need to
be thinking about oh is this person you
know uh uh does this person have this
specific neurodivergence you don't need
to go that far all you need to do is be
patient be kind and try and think about
okay what is it they're trying to tell
me and what is it saying to me if you
try and come at them from your own
perspective when somebody's explaining
something if you're not sure if you're
confused don't get frustrated don't get
annoyed don't be there going oh no
that's wrong tell them how it's coming
across you say oh hey
um so if I've got what you're saying
correct I think you're trying to say
that uh you want to make this or make
the game like that or do these kind of
things or bring in this mechanic
um and you might be right well that's
perfect or they might go oh that's not
quite what I'm trying to say and they
might try and explain it another way
work with them try and figure out where
the confusion is happening and the thing
is is that that effort is how you make a
great game because it's only when we you
know we work with different people we
work with people with new ideas we will
attack it from different directions who
uh look at the same information and come
up with a completely different way of uh
interpreting it that we can make the
best thing I mean that's the point of a
game Jam right you've got thousands and
thousands of Jammers all over the world
taking part on game Jam all with just
the one theme the same theme and no two
games are going to be the same game
there may not even be games that are
close to similar and some will be so
unbelievably amazing some will be ideas
that you've never dreamed of and the
reason that happens is because people
are working together all over the place
coming up with new ideas bringing new
things to the table people are being
inspired by things both in games and
outside of games like art by Culture by
music by film by books by Nature
anything can Inspire turn into what is
going to be you know some fantastic
mechanic or novel way of approaching
games that we may never have thought of
before and that's one of the reasons why
game jamb is so fantastic is that it
brings all these people together with
all our differences and changes our
divergences and our similarities and
asks us hey you want to make something
cool and of course we say yes so I'm
super excited to be here uh for Global
game Jam 2023 I'm really looking forward
to making something cool me myself I'm
not sure what I'm gonna make yet but
we've got to find out
um and I'm looking forward to seeing
what you make too so
Global game time 2023
a good year to listen a good year to be
uh to be making something interesting uh
and a good year to be
promoting neurodiversity have a great
Global game Jam uh I myself am going to
be doing the 48 hours or not on the last
few days in the last weekend uh you take
out whichever way that you want every
way is valid
um and I'll see you at the finish line
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
very very awesome to hear from our first
UK Community Spotlight member I do love
the discussion of neurodivergence and
how that plays into to Game Dev I think
that's super important and it's
definitely like he touched on how you
approach working with different teams
and how Global game jams or game jams in
general can be really good for your
social skills as well because obviously
a lot of Dev is collaborative despite
the amount of people we've spoken to
today who've been solo devs which is
also very cool
right I feel like a game Jam is such a
good opportunity to if you are a solo
Dev to experience developing on a team
too and we've had a few people talk
about that and and really practicing
those skills and how to work together
creatively it's just it's a really good
opportunity here yeah I think uh the
thing that I found most helpful when I
started doing them um before I started
working full-time was understanding how
different departments have to work with
each other and complement each other
um because it's something that from the
outside you wouldn't really have any
idea of like does this go to Art first
or who do I talk to about narrative
design who is the the programming who to
where do we talk about this particular
thing so there's definitely a really
important uh important and fun thing to
get involved in yes yes uh next up we
are talking to another uh Community
Spotlight remember from the UK
um joining us is Caleb Anderson hi hello
I'll try saying that without a voice
crack what was everyone doing great you
Caleb
I am very good it's very late here in
the UK but
still happy to chat it's been very cool
to actually kind of see everybody's time
zones all over the world you can see
it's still sunny for me it's lovely uh I
imagine it's not quite the case in
Liverpool and Mary you're where are you
based I don't remember I'm in Chicago so
we are it's it's barely light out but
the snow is falling sideways so you
can't regardless they're all making it
work you're right right uh so Caleb how
do you feel about the the theme reveal
today
it was quite interesting because
like watching the video obviously you
start to get an idea for the theme and
you start to build it up and then
obviously you get to the point where
it's like the theme this year is and all
of a sudden it came up with the word
roots and my brain wouldn't really going
okay what can I do with this and it's so
interesting because your brain can go
from having 50 billion ideas to all of a
sudden having that one idea that you go
this is what I want to do
you've done five Global games yes this
is my next yeah this is my sixth game
Jam I've been a site organizer for the
past this will be my third year
so what uh what tidbits from those five
years almost six of experience do you
think you can share with any newcomers
I think the first thing will be
obviously people sign up they see the 48
hours and they think I have to be going
at 100 for that whole 48 Hours
especially if you're new to it don't
feel like you have to be working the
whole 48 Hours get some rest trust me
but
it's one of those that if you don't take
that rest you will see your project
suffer and that's something that no one
wants to see when you're working on
something like this take that risk if
you need it remember to eat remember to
drink remember to look after yourself
that's my biggest tip it's just not
worth it otherwise right we don't want
anyone to burn themselves out just
exactly you're not going to have a good
time it's not in the spirit of the whole
thing it's definitely not a good idea
yeah your brain's not it at its best
when it hasn't slept or had anything to
drink in a long
time and this is coming from yeah this
is coming from someone who made that
exact mistake like in my first game Jam
I stayed away the whole 48 hours I
probably slept for a week afterwards
yeah I'm sure that's a hard crash yeah I
get that yep 100 how do you feel about
the um diversifiers and and how much
attention do you think uh jammins should
pay attention to those
yes to diversify you that they are
possibly my second favorite thing to
look at when it comes to game Jam first
obviously being the theme diversify it
for anyone who doesn't know what they
are their little extra challenges that
you can set yourself as you go through
developing your game
and they're quite interesting because
they force you to think about things in
a way that you probably wouldn't
otherwise and it's always important even
if you're thinking oh I'm not going to
touchse at all just take a once read
whether that's at the start whether
that's halfway through have a read of it
because you might look at something and
go actually I can tie this into what I'm
doing so if you take that chance read
through the diversifiers there's a lot
every year they're chosen by a wonderful
team I was involved with it a couple of
years ago
have a read through it all see if
there's any that jump out to you if not
that's fine if there is have a go at
including it even if you have a go and
decide halfway through actually I don't
want to do this that's fine game jams
are for experimenting
you were uh also work on board games
right
yes so in all the time I've been doing
Global game Jam not once have I touched
a line of code and I think if I tried to
I would probably not be able to do half
as well so you've made board game board
games every time
yeah wow cool
that's so awesome so how do you feel
like uh uh I don't even know how to
phrase this question like where do you
start if if we have people who want to
specifically get into the board game
side of things what do you think is the
like the beginning processes of
Designing a board game
well one of the easiest things I think
is Hop on Amazon order just one of the
sort of cheap kits that you can get you
get a bunch of stuff just lay out on in
front of you and go okay I could use
this for this I could use this for this
and you just have a think of the things
that you've got there because you don't
have to go out and spend 100 200 however
much just buy a cheap 20 pound 20 kit
pop out in front of you and go okay how
can I make this work
very very cool I didn't even know those
existed does this uh this oh I feel like
this whole stream so far has been a
bunch of like finding out about
resources that make barriers to entries
so small which is awesome like it's it's
so so cool
um so when you're designing board games
for for game Jam thinking of the themes
in mind you know I I don't want you to
spoil anything if you're participating
but if we're thinking about board games
and Roots what what comes to your head
well it depends on how you look at
routes like I've seen lots of different
comments in twitch chat in the YouTube
chat about how people are approaching it
and I think even if I gave you like five
billion ideas in the call there's going
to be someone who comes up with
something else so
it's just have a think on the theme for
yourself and think okay what does that
term mean to me that's what I've done
every year and I find that that's it
takes on quite an interesting form of
its own because you might even get
towards the end and you go actually now
that I think on it
it could also mean this and even if you
can't include it whilst you're in the
game channel there's no there's no
stopping you
once you've recovered from Global game
Jam go into another event or even just
tinkering in your own time
I think that you can also find more
inspiration a lot of the time if you're
pulling from something that means
something to you personally I feel like
it's a great way to stay motivated and
to come up with something cohesive is
like if you really think about what the
word means to you I think that's that's
a really good tip yeah and really bring
heart to the project because that you
know we all know that's that's what sets
incredible creative projects apart
whatever the medium whether it's uh
board games video games not a game at
all so that is such a good approach for
sure definitely
um Caleb anything you're especially
excited about this year
um I mean I'm excited every year like
it's one of those that
even if everything else in the world
seems to go a bit awry you always know
end of January start of February Global
game Jam sitting there
it's there it's something to enjoy so I
think the experience as a whole is
something that everyone could sit down
and enjoy and whether you're doing it on
your own like I normally do or whether
you're working with a whole group
uh being a site organizer I get to
witness so many incredibly talented
people whether they're just tinkering
for the first time or they've got
University degrees in game design seeing
what people can come up with with a
single theme of 48 hours is absolutely
amazing
definitely it's kind of nice like like
you said knowing that no matter what you
have this
set period of time every year where you
just get to be creative I feel like I
like you're probably excited about it
for months um and it's it's really nice
seeing how many people are recurring
participants as well um I feel like most
people we've spoken to have done it more
than one time and it it I don't know
it's just such a lovely community
yeah definitely like the first day that
it was announced that sites were being
open I was on there signing up because
you know it's something to enjoy as I
said yeah so do you are you a solo or do
you work with a team
I used to work as part of a team but I
find oftentimes working solo can be
quite an interesting experience in and
of itself because
it sort of allows you to experience
things that you probably wouldn't do
when you're part of a group totally
you've got solo control over everything
so you get to have a tinker with the art
with the music whatever it is and
if you've not got experience in it oh
well just it gives you a chance to try
something new if you have experience
after this yeah yeah you've tried it
exactly yeah yeah
you know very very cool
um any closing thoughts for us Caleb
um any passing comments you've Jam is
with
uh as I've said enjoy the experience
that is a great motive and as everybody
keeps saying but I want to reiterate
make sure you sleep and drink water Andy
yeah because I'm fairly certain I'm
fairly certain if you forget to sleep or
eat I'm sure we can send Tim down
you're down to force you to sleep
don't make him do it y'all
like thank you so much for joining us
Caleb and good luck we can't wait to see
what you come up with yeah thank you for
having me
Caleb
what Paul
um it is time to have another uh
discussion about our responses real
quick
um of course we saw from them earlier in
the show and it was awesome uh coherence
uh they make multiplayer games easy
which is very very cool it takes just a
few moments to configure a scene and
game object so they can see each other
over the network we saw it happen in
real time part of the stream it was just
so so impressive using free Cloud
hosting options you can then deploy a
project online directly from within the
unity editor and even share your webgl
build hosted at coherence Network engine
SDK and platform that lets you make and
run scalable multiplayer games in
minutes a full featured toolbox for
multiplayer networking that gives you
everything you need to develop test and
run your game build Virtual Worlds Rim
based games or a combination of both
automatically scalable in the cloud and
on bare metal and they had like one of
the cutest ads I've ever seen it's a
really good trailer for coherence that
is you know I think multiplayer games
are very intimidating especially when it
comes to a game jam it seems like it's
extremely difficult
coherence makes it look a hell of a lot
easier it looks it looks awesome very
very impressive nominal tool yeah and it
is applicable to someone no matter what
kind of computer you're using it is just
it is something that you should check
out it is not just for PC folks
which is always great
um and I believe next up if they are
ready for us our next Community
Spotlight is with uh
yeah they are ready um with Iran
hello hello uh would you like to
introduce yourself
yeah uh my name is and I'm a video game
uh developer programmer for seven years
now and uh yeah I'm here in uh clone
Germany right now but yeah
so what is the uh situation like for
game devs in Iran
uh yeah in uh General I think probably
you have heard about the recent news and
uh what is happening in Iran so maybe I
skipped at that part because you already
know uh this kind of stuff so yeah uh
about game developers specifically
neuron now
the biggest challenges is for connecting
to work because in general game
development uh is the best industry that
people are pretty much very
International
and people like to connect to each other
all around the world and which is
something that we also need to and
like to have a
conversations interactions and
everything with all around the world and
this became a very big challenge for
game developers now in Iran Because the
Internet connection is a big problem now
and we have very unstable internet
connection actually which is called from
the restrictions from the government and
also some other restrictions from
outside outside of the country of the
country sorry and
like some sanctions which are kinda not
directed to the government and and said
to the people so it just bothers
everybody
and so so yeah this is this is the
biggest problem I say and one of the
other problems can be like
um censorships or some bands that we
have have like the like if if you're you
have a female character in your game
they may remove your game from the
episodes uh local episodes
so and even uh we had a case that they
removed the game because there was a
rainbow in one of the images which they
said yeah it's represented for lgbtq
plus Community but
right it's just those are definitely
challenges
um is there anything that the gamedev
community or Gamers can do to help raise
awareness or help devs in your community
yeah uh we have we had a game Jam uh
recently uh for uh women life Freedom
um uh movement now which was a very good
and we with with the media that we had
uh we could raise a little bit of
awareness about it what is happening and
in general I I say you just uh uh like
know what is happening and uh trying to
uh
yeah uh show it to a board that
um
have some
uh sorry just uh oh yeah okay to yeah to
stay informed and just to know what is
happening it helps you in uh anyway like
if you know that the people of of Iran
are just normal people and that are
dealing with this kind of stuff uh you
probably approach them differently like
they are not like their government and
yeah yeah of course and that's
definitely a tough thing to communicate
if you're dealing with uh with
censorship
um it's something people definitely deal
with on a global scale is is uh Rocky
internet restrictions what are some of
the solutions that Iranian game devs
have found for dealing with like poor
internet speeds
you have your uh actually when I was
talking with my friends uh they're
saying that like they don't know uh when
they have internet or not and they're
just trying uh different vpns different
practices every now and then and some of
them work for an hour and they just stop
working for another hour so yeah it's
just pretty tough yeah
Oh no you're okay
yeah
freelancer people are also having a lot
of troubles and problems like yeah it's
good that we know about this kind of
problems that they have so we can
understand uh better if if we are
working with uh people yeah
yeah so considering some of those
difficulties which are pretty major and
and
make doing
anything creative
um difficult in a lot of cases
um is there anything you're especially
proud of that's that's come out of the
Game Dev scene uh
where you're from but you want to give a
shout out to or something that you want
to highlight
um
not some
something but I mean
just being a game developer and
surviving and continue working I mean
that's that's just enough because
uh you can
yeah you can easily give up in this kind
of situations but yeah yeah and uh also
when I saw those many games that people
made for the for the game Jam was just
pretty hopeful yeah it just gives you a
lot of Hope and you can see that people
really care
yeah
um I know the there is a link to where
people can check out some more from the
women life Freedom game Jam which is
um it's a itch.io sorry slash Jam slash
women Dash life Dash Freedom oh we can
leave a link there there you go um and
and that's absolutely awesome there's
also a timeline of events for everything
that's going on in Iran right now on
i-rant timelines sorry I ran
timelines.com yes I read that
incorrectly I read it as I rant
iron timelines.com
um and we also have a trusted
organization who's fighting against
Injustice in Iran which is uh
ps752justice.com if you want to check
that out and Amnesty International also
has more information
um a lot of good resources there thank
you so much for for sharing those and
yeah you're right that
anyone continuing to work and make
anything creative under those
circumstances at all is super inspiring
and awesome and um
Yeah it's you're doing an amazing job so
thank you
thank you thank you for uh giving uh
giving me this opportunity to talk and
of course
um enjoy the the game jam and uh much
love and support to everybody in Iran
thank you so much yeah just incredible
that you are still making video games
for us to all enjoy so thank you it is
thank you so much
thank you alrighty see yep
slightly too soon I was like bye yeah
it's uh so much of this keeps making me
realize how easy my job is yes speaking
repeatedly like oh and I thought that
anything I did was hard and it's not
um between limited connectivity and I
mean just censorship and not not being
able to guess even sometimes where
that's gonna hit is um yeah it's it's
incredible try making art and making
something as a team in those
circumstances is yeah wow and not giving
up under the circumstances is yeah yeah
it's incredible and yeah like the the
woman earlier who was talking about how
she couldn't study because
the teacher was basically a known
Predator to women
um but so she was like so I want that
and I'll learn by myself and I just keep
we keep getting these stories that I'm
like damn yeah yeah wow I saw an
obstacle and I said nope yeah we went
around that obstacle yes
Ah that's why I love these Community
spotlights because you see the many
different different circumstances in
which people are still creating and
they're still doing it yeah incredible
I'm like so touched I'm it's making me
emotional
um
it happens I'm a softy what do you want
me to say
it's fine it's casual so something that
I care about a whole lot and try to talk
about as much as I possibly can um in
Game Dev in general is uh accessibility
is something that's super important to
me
um so I wanted to read a piece from AWS
for games which is an easy to use
service and tool set that will make your
game fun and accessible which is a win
for absolutely everybody
um you can use Amazon to transcribe to
create voice commands for your game
Amazon translate to create cross-lingual
chat or Amazon poly to create speech in
dozens of languages which is something
that can be really prohibitive to a lot
of smaller Studios uh it can be really
challenging
um also all ggj participants read
receive a hundred dollars in AWS
promotional credits which is awesome uh
you can send an email to AWS for Games
events at amazon.com to include Global
game jam and sorry include Global game
Jam in the subject line in your company
name country and AWS account ID in the
body of the email and an AWS
representative we'll get back to you
within two business days so that's
definitely something that if you aren't
considering it
um I would love to see you consider it
because accessibility is super important
and it only gets easier once you've done
it the first time every time you have to
do it after that it becomes easier to
implement because as you have solved the
problem already so definitely something
worth considering we're going to jump
straight into a video from AWS right now
whether you're a team of one or one
thousand only one thing really matters
making a game that players want to play
developers are imagining future games
that Delight players and require
solutions to support their dreams
players expect games to have Fast
Response times and High Fidelity
experiences on any device anywhere in
the world to achieve this more and more
developers are turning to the cloud AWS
for games provide a broad portfolio of
industry-specific products and solutions
from AWS and AWS Partners to help you
build faster run smarter and grow your
games AWS for games portfolio covers 12
solution areas spanning the three phases
of game development when building AWS
will help you to modernize your
architecture and move your production
pipelines to the cloud enabling you to
recruit and build diverse teams around
the globe not limited to a physical
location when running a game AWS can
help you streamline operations deploy
the right compute and accelerated
networking options to deliver low
latency game experiences provide
real-time and serverless analytics to
help better understand player behavior
and help you harden your back end
against DDOS and other malicious attacks
to grow your player base AWS can help
you acquire and retain users with an
engaging Community experience with
twitch Amazon Luna and machine learning
tools with 175 fully featured services
and more functionality than any other
cloud provider AWS infrastructure is
trusted by over 90 percent of the
largest public game companies including
epic EA Ubisoft Sony Nintendo Zynga
Rovio and more need help getting started
visit the AWS for games landing page for
a customized onboarding experience take
one of our structured learning classes
or dive deep into the 12 solution areas
either way we want to help you create
the next amazing game welcome to aw s
for games
one of the first Atlantic Canada sites
to come online
hello Global game Jammers of 2023 my
name is Dr Rina Webby my pronouns are
she her I'm the professor of computer
science at Dalhousie University in
Halifax Nova Scotia Canada
Dalhousie sits on the unseated ancestral
territory of the mcmahagi we are all
treaty people
this year Dalhousie University and shift
key Labs have teamed up with local
businesses and game design companies as
well as non-profits all around Halifax
to hold one of the first Atlantic Canada
sites to come online
to reach an even bigger audience we have
satellite sites in New Glasgow and
Yarmouth in case they can't get to
Halifax we got you covered
the game Jam has a huge commitment to
Equitable culture because it includes
these aspects of diversity inclusion
accessibility that we know are necessary
to make our field more inviting for
people
the diverse element comes from the
participation of sites all around the
world that's a commitment we are making
to diversity by engaging in this
activity that we love making games
together
our game Jam sites welcome people of all
backgrounds orientations skill levels
socioeconomic status regarding
regardless of education level
that means if you're currently working
at a retail store but you've always
wanted to make games you can come to
this event
and that is inclusive
game jams are an important opportunity
to invite people into our space to make
the tech industry more inviting and who
doesn't want to make games
in this way we can say that we're giving
a commitment to inclusivity which is
important because historically Equity
deserving groups have been
underrepresented in stem Fields stem
being science technology engineering and
Mathematics
this is especially true of computer
science and unfortunately the game
design industry doesn't have the best
reputation for culture either
historically
nowadays we are moving to change the
status quo we are trying to create this
culture that brings the fun and
enjoyment and passion and love for games
as well as the idea that we can be kind
to each other and learn together
Dalhousie is one of the few sites to do
both the game jam and the game Jam next
for our younger participants to
encourage youth of all backgrounds to
consider stem as a viable career we have
to engage them early so non-profits such
as ignite and Supernova who are helping
us with the game Jam are also of great
importance here
alongside our collaborators at code
ninja Halifax we've prepared design
tutorials and exciting programming
opportunities for younger coders
the game Jam also provides an accessible
learning platform
so we all learn in different ways we all
grow in different ways and we all have
different interests within the large
scheme of games if you're interested in
art there's a place for you if you're
interested in programming there's a
place for you if you're a writer well
games need story and narrative a lot of
the time
so there's an accessibility of material
there's more ways to learn than just
sitting in class and doing a lecture
we're inviting people to learn by doing
to learn by participating
and it's not just receiving information
in this form that you are now you can
learn from each other
if you have come individually we will
find you a team no problem
if you are not very good coder but you
want to be team up with a great coder if
you're already an excellent coder and
you want to gain a different skill set
find someone who isn't a quota to team
up with and learn from each other
in this way you can find a place for
exploration and interest
at doll it's really important too that
we think about how you can use computer
science to explore and be part of the
world
game jams offer this opportunity to take
that part of computer science that
passion that we have for gaming and play
and bring that to engage in this area of
computer science and stem
game jamming gives us an opportunity to
explore new skills to learn in a safe
space and hey if the game doesn't work
out that's okay it was only 48 Hours of
gameplay and trying what's really
important is that you learn from the
game Jam
exploration from the game Jam can also
lead into career opportunities not just
like computer science programs but also
graduate level programs if you are a PhD
or a master's student or interested in
doing Graduate Studies there are
academic groups such as HCI for good my
lab that explores games in an academic
setting for Education collaboration or
even the design of games and algorithms
you can do a PhD on looking at games for
mental health and education to battle
stigma or you might be interested in the
design of algorithms either way this
game Jam is meant to be a fun
collaborative educational experience and
I'm so excited for all of the new games
that we're going to make and I'm so
excited for all of the people we're
going to meet so let's go out there and
jam
buy from Canada
a very big thank you to Rena from Canada
there people yeah
uh awesome to see and agree with
everything she said which I keep saying
about everybody really
um so great they're doing such great
things I know
uh next up we have it joining us David
from Mexico
hello
how you doing
fine fine uh here in Mexico we have an
excellent weather and we are ready to
all the sites in Mexico are ready to
begin with technology
it's wonderful beautiful country I've
only been once and I hope to go back
again this year I love Mexico yeah it's
lovely I I mean in every part of the
year is different what you can see here
in Mexico in the spring you can see the
Violet flowers
November you can see orange flowers all
around it's an amazing Place yeah
um I'm like jealous not that California
is not also beautiful but we don't have
the seasons
um so what's the The Game Dev scene uh
like in Mexico and how many Jammers do
you know out there well it's very
interesting because in Mexico sometimes
we thought as Mexico as a little country
we Telegraph Mexico as for example or
Colombia but Mexico is in fact the same
size more or less like Brazil so it's
enormous oh sure yeah it's like a lot of
conference so in the north of Mexico we
have one kind of game developers in the
south of Mexico we have another kind of
game developers we have different
structures we have different a kind of
Industries and for example in the north
of Mexico in the center of Mexico we
have a industry that works a lot with
AAA industry in USA in Canada in the
south of Mexico we have a very
interesting in the community particular
developers because we are working with
our indigenous cool tours we are working
with a
medium to share about culture and
nothing so much as a business as we
understand it
it's more like it's art yeah sure
yeah in fact for example in California
in Tijuana there's an indigenous
community that has a this the health of
the communities in the USA and the other
half is in Mexico so the Mexican flag
make their a main Legend their main a
meat uh by the game to share with it
that's really cool yeah we have a lot of
interesting projects because
we share a lot of backgrounds and
cultural backgrounds here in Mexico so
we are working with
um a lot of perspectives about violence
not just the industry not just the
culture we have a lot of events from
different sites and from different
topics so it's a very a multicultural
region here in Mexico that's awesome and
am I writing thinking that uh game Jam
actually kind of had a hand in helping
the games industry in Mexico grow
yeah sure for example a our country has
been a like 10 years making a day sorry
sorry you got a delivery hi
game Jam for 10 years and
for example the first years of the
Global India was just working with a how
to make games
how do we begin to making games and a
lot of experiments were there but right
now we're working with a
in studios we're working with colleges
we're working with a lot of people
around the industry making it happen a
one big example the first time we made a
global gaming site on Mexico City it was
with with the health of the Mexican
Government
with the ministry of culture
but right now we are making the game
jams into Mexico City with the support
of colleges public and private colleges
Mexican
Ministry of culture and also with a lot
of Studios studios that works in Mexico
and the works with other part Partners
in other parts a and another example
because of kovid and peace a digital
realization of the global Indian the
community in Mexico created like a a
part of the global Indian that is
digital only because a lot of friends
from South America came to jam with us
so we have in some sites in Mexico the
registration of people from Cuba from
Venezuela
because we we shared the chance they go
to the sites on their locals but the
project is created
a digital platform
so you're really selling me on the
Mexican games industry I'm like now I
want to go yeah
sure
that's another thing that happened we
begin to be to make a digital event and
in the game jams in a digital version
before we have like eight years making
the digital events because someone who
lives in Mexico City they cannot go to
for example Tijuana it's so long to go
and it's so expensive although it's our
own country because of the distance so
right we have a lot of communities and
also if we look for cities we have some
cities right now in Mexico where it says
now the snow is falling and some cities
who were well we are not typical it's so
diverse yeah
we have some Gamers that are in a snow
country and some other yamas that are in
the beach for example in Cancun making a
gate yeah I feel like because of of
those routes that you're talking about
um I feel like there's some really
really cool stuff that could come out of
the the theme from the the jam is in in
your area
um especially if the teams who are
actually participating in the JAMA of
that Multicultural as well yeah yeah it
would be very interesting and in fact
the games in Mexico are every time very
interesting because you could see that a
maybe they are not so a Mexican in the
way that we expect you know because well
well we already know automatic is here
and that's not something that kind of
loves so much but are very interesting
because for example I remember in a game
a game I wrote a cat that I uh and it's
like the spirit of the Catherine or the
home and it's very very Mexican
you know because it's like end of the
day of the day
yeah you're looking at a designer prong
aesthetic is like well we have a lot to
to give to the industry and we are
completed we have the
um with the time we could be more
integrated to the industry yeah there
are a lot of projects with with all the
world well uh you sold me on it I love
the set of that uh are there any like
studios in Mexico or games that you want
to give a shout out to the audience
that's watching
well we have a lot of Studios a for
example a man eater games it's a very
interesting Studio because it's a LGBT
friendly studio and it also is running
by by a woman here in Mexico because we
are a conservative a a culture it's kind
of weird
some a woman in the in a tech industry
with an LGBT perspective it's having a
lot of success it's wonderful that's
great yeah that's amazing
and we have a lot of young designers
that a I'm going to to bring a hits I'm
pretty sure for example New Zealand is a
great designer that you should follow he
makes uh games based on lecture on text
but he's also thinking about the
Labyrinth of the language
so he makes something very interesting
about it that sounds awesome to me
on three-dimensional spaces and if those
those kind of games are amazing very
very cool yeah
um
so where can people find you I know you
said you have a Twitter
yeah but you can find a in Mexico we
have a lot of communities we have igla
we have a Debs BG we have layout that is
we need a lot of communities to cover on
the country so a if you want any
information about Mexican industry you
could contact for a layout a layout
Forum but well in Spanish photo layout
so you can contact us and we can give
you uh any information that you want
about a Mexican industry and also well
we have to collaborate much more with
some other countries and as well if you
want a some a rise with some other Latin
communities we also work with them so
just okay I love the enthusiasm David
it's awesome and it's absolutely it
seems like you're doing really cool
creative stuff and yeah really cool
creative people too from all different
backgrounds and cultures and just like
melding together I'm excited to see what
you guys create yeah me too yeah thanks
awesome everything is
created the spirit
the ones who who are who prepare the
pigs yeah apparently we just got over 16
000 Germans signed up which is wild and
I'm now expecting a whole bunch of
people from Mexico which is super cool
so thank you so much for joining us
David and uh good luck to all the
Mexican game Jammers
bye thank you everybody's so nice very
cool it was so nice and everyone all
over the world is is doing something and
I mean if you want to get involved
yeah I've done 405 and it's it is super
fun and everyone has always been really
really nice and
I'm in the camp where I feel like I
don't have the skill set I'm like
whatever wrong bring to the table I
don't know how to code I don't know how
to draw you've got it next year you'll
like even production you know like like
what you're doing right now hosting is a
different kind of production we have to
manage what's going on and you need
producers uh that that definitely helps
out a lot of teams so I can help do that
I can do it better I'm an idea person
I'll just like throw ideas at the wall
you got it
um so we're gonna jump into a video from
one of our sponsors uh side effects
before we head into our final segment
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
our next guest is Michael from triangle
Interactive
hey how's it going everyone I gotta ask
about the too much tomato oh yeah that's
just kind of my studio name
um but I'm here to talk about triangle
interactive Arts Collective today yeah
so uh what what can you tell us uh we're
a group of Indie developers and creative
people in the Triangle region of North
Carolina in the US
we're a pretty new group that's mostly
focused on just supporting Indies and
beginners with Game Dev and this is
actually our first Global game Jam so
we're really excited for it but you have
participated yeah in in other game jams
right this is not your first game Jam
correct yeah this is my first Global
game Jam but not my first game Jam okay
so what are you doing to prepare for
this one
uh well I just learned the theme and uh
I'm mostly uh trying to make sure to be
a good host and make sure the venue is
good to make sure we got good snacks uh
make sure I communicate kind of like the
right attitude to bring into it to
everyone in the collective so yeah we're
really excited for that What attitude is
that that you're hoping to you know kind
of share with everybody well I do
actually have a slide deck to shoot here
for five let's do it tips
so yeah I think like a lot of people uh
kind of have a vague idea of what
they're trying to get out of a game Jam
when they start like they kind of they
have this idea in the back of their head
that they want to make a game
um but I think it's really important to
really clarify which what your goals are
and kind of uh go into it
uh you know in the right headspace so
the first tip that I have is like to
clearly Define your goal and what you're
looking to get out of the jam
um that can be a ton of different things
right I think a great one is just to
have fun uh you might want to practice a
very specific new skill you might want
to make friends with game developers in
your area you might want to learn to
collaborate better especially if you're
like a beginner or solo developer like
how do you actually work on a team with
other developers and then another one
people have a lot is to just like finish
anything
um and so I always recommend in our
group we're doing this as well like a
lot of people will post I'm a programmer
and I want to work on a team but no one
ever posts like I just want to have fun
with this Jam or I just want to practice
this one skill so I think it's really
important to
both Define like what you want to do and
what your skills are and also like
what you uh what you want out of the
experience so that way when you're
forming teams you like
can kind of mesh on that same aspect too
right you're all in it to have fun or
you all wanted to make like a hilarious
joke game or whatever so yeah that's
number one
number two is start really small like
I'm sure you hear this all the time from
people uh as they're like number one
game Jam tip it's like keep the scope
really small yeah because in addition to
like your you know people always say
like don't crunch in game jams and I
think that's really important too but if
you Scope your game too big it's gonna
incentivize you to want to like work and
try to finish it and like another way
you can avoid crunching on something is
to just really scope it down small
um so I I try to actually this kind of
Blends into number three is like block
out your time and try to leave half of
the time for bug fixing and polish like
in the 48 hour Jam like weekend style
like
if you leave that last Sunday entirely
for fixing bugs and polishing it's like
you're having such a great day on Sunday
just add it you're like oh I just
thought of a hilarious joke to add into
the game like what if we make this silly
sound effect and just throw it in there
and then you just have like this great
these Great Moments with all your
friends and collaborators that you might
not have had if you're like rushing to
get this big game idea done in the last
day yeah I haven't heard that one before
but that is a really really good idea
yeah slope it down to one day for
initial development and then bug fixes
polish and some more fun creative stuff
on the second day that's that's a really
good call yeah absolutely and then
yeah just like I like to use Google
Calendar and literally like just drag
the little blocks of time like this is
when I will have this done this is when
I'm taking my lunch break this is when
I'm going for a run this is when I'm
like you know we're gonna do a little
walk around the block and talk with the
with the um that's a great one too
exercise you got to keep it up I
currently have a I have a little bike
underneath my desk because I was like
I'm gonna be sitting for a long time
today so I've literally been biking
between uh that's awesome
yeah whenever I hit writer's block I
have to like run around the block
because that's the only way to get my
brain working again that's great advice
very good for you it's so true and if
you've got like a group it's it's like
really fun to just walk away from the
computer get outside and like you come
back with such Clarity and focus when
you come back to your game so it's like
you're not gonna if you take 10 minutes
away from the computer to to walk that's
like an essential part of the jam in my
experience like not just you know go and
pedal to the metal with the programming
yeah
so we're already talking about this
take care of your human needs in a game
Jam you know
you know get rest do some movement get
some breaks uh sustenance and sleep so
when you're working with the triangle
interactive community and you'll it
sounds like what you're doing is sort of
community leadership how do you make
sure people are doing these things this
is something that you try to enforce or
do you let people sort of take their own
approaches to it I let people take their
own approaches
um but I try to lead by example right
yeah I'll be like hey I'm gonna go run
and grab lunch let's go
um or like hey let's take a quick walk
you know that sort of thing I'm also
closing the jam site at 10 pm oh nice
yeah oh yeah so good idea I feel like
that that kind of helps for the on-site
Jam but you know obviously people do
know their own limits and and you know
you kind of have to respect that it's
true yeah sure
but yeah having lots of snacks and
drinks that aren't caffeinated or
alcoholic is helpful too so like you
know honestly yeah we we have a lot of
like seltzer water and we're always
crazy about our celtsies in our
community like I'm always bringing
bringing a cooler to all of our
co-working events and stuff so that's
really helpful to you know encourage
like the water drinking as well which
people say a lot
um and the last one is to like make
friends
um a lot of times the relationships you
make with your collaborators and fellow
Jammers are more important than your
output you know you've been hearing it
from a lot of people on the stream today
years down the line you still like talk
to the people that you you know did that
one game Jam back with in the day and
you know maybe you work at a studio
together now or maybe these kind of
friendships that you make during a game
Jam they have these wonderful ways of
spiraling out into all these fantastic
things so just have a great time and
make friends it takes pressure off too
yeah have a great time make friends it's
sort of my life motto I'm doing okay
have a good time so in terms of like
bringing all these people together
making friends fostering that Community
um what you're doing is very cool with
triangle interactive do you have any
tips for how people who might want to do
the same thing in other regions could
approach Community Building like this
yeah I was going to make a point to talk
about this before you kicked me off the
stream like first of all go on Meetup or
go on Eventbrite and just kind of search
to see if there's any groups especially
doing like Indie organizing in your area
like uh you'll a lot of times they'll be
co-working or play testing events these
sorts of groups with Indie developers
kind of forming collectives and
co-working together they're happening
all over the place and if you are
searching and searching and can't find
one
what I recommend doing is just starting
one it'll take a while of just planting
your flag in the ground and waving it
around
you're going to feel a little silly when
no one shows up to your events sometimes
but that's all part of it and you know
network with other creative groups in
your area you know if if you can't find
any game developers find some writers
find some painters find some artists
they do uh kind of creative co-working
sometimes too and basically all the
little connections start forming and
your group will start growing
organically but you just kind of have to
get out there and uh you know go talk to
people
it's great advice do you have any advice
for people for whom if this is their
first game Jam or they've done game jams
as a solo Dev before maybe this is their
first time working on a team
yeah um so that it's their first time or
their first time working on a team I'd
say like
you want to
um another reason why you want to like
take care of your health and your um
like your breaks and feeding yourself
and sleeping well is because you want to
be a good teammate right so like if you
if you're like grumpy because you
haven't eaten all day then
you know just make sure you're taking
care of yourself and encouraging other
people to take care of themselves too
yeah and keep an open mind and
collaborate well yeah
all great advice
um is there anything else that you want
to leave people with as they apparently
against 16 000 people have signed up uh
as they head into this this year's
Global game gym absolutely 16 000 people
remember don't let the fun end after
global game Jam if you had a fun time
collaborating with people in your
community keep going and keep like
hosting events and doing other game jams
doing other things like if you're
feeling any sort of like imposter
syndrome or anything like that the way
that I found to get past that is to just
meet real life people and like talk to
them and like feel like you're part of a
community and people are really
welcoming as you've seen from this
stream so totally go out there and keep
doing it great tip uh last question just
how did you feel about Roots
um it's gonna be a good one because
there's gonna be a lot of really awesome
conceptual games and also stuff with
plants which I quite like too
we could all get behind that yeah
clearly I'm in that's my entire
background clearly
alrighty well thank you so much for
joining us uh Michael and good luck with
this year's Global game Jam awesome
thank you all so much thank you Michael
what a great uh just presentation from
all the different communities and
hearing all the tips and the theme and
I leave today feeling different about
the world honestly like I'm like wow
everyone's really nice and everyone
really cares and like you can kind of
forget that stuff when a lot of the
discourse you see about Game Dev is on
Twitter or whatever whereas like talking
to people like this it's just just so
nice it's a community that wants to help
each other and wants to learn and that's
so incredible to remember it's not a big
competition it's not like who can drink
the least amount of water at the gym and
just leave the least in this week yeah
right
let's all just make something and also
be okay at the end of it yeah
the amount of people who like make
friends is is the great mono because it
can that can change your life and keep
you motivated and keep you like even
outside of the jams you have somebody to
bounce some ideas off and Studios come
out of this kind of thing you know it's
absolutely like uh I help host
these and
a lot of devs with like oh I met my
partner at a game jam and here they are
making like turning their game Jam game
into a game that they're publishing it's
really wonderful very cool
um related to that we have to thank all
about sponsors one last time so let me
just read through the list before we
head off thank you to dot Big Bang
coherence crazygames yahaha Google
Firebase Photon unity in world global
engagement center of the US Department
of State cubes UK games fun GitHub
avaton Autodesk Intel side effects plus
music AWS for games incredible Weaver
Microsoft Xbox hyperpad construct yoyo
games DDM Nimble giant geopipe Rich cost
and procedural worlds
and I think
that is it for this year Mac where
should people go to sign up
uh you can go to
globalgamejam.org and uh find a site
near you and join
find a team and and get started even if
you don't have any skills
more skills than you think you just yes
there's so many people here you want to
help
I think like being willing to do it and
get involved at all is kind of a skill
you should give yourself credit for like
even being curious about it is is a good
place to start joining a thing that you
aren't familiar with with a bunch of
people you don't know is super scary so
if you're even considering doing it that
is a huge critic to you I think huge leg
up for sure yeah yeah can't wait to see
what everyone comes up with absolutely
it's gonna be exciting it's gonna be
good here I could feel it all right well
thank you to everybody who has joined us
today
um thank you to both of you and to
everybody backstage who's helping run
this whole thing you guys are fantastic
and I think before we head up we are
going to rerun the theme Reveal video um
so I'll just say happy Global game Jam
everybody good luck happy jamming
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign